what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
so by the time you guys are watching
this video I'll be in California and I
was trying to figure out what kind of
content I was going to make this week
and so what you'll see down in the
description is a temporary schedule for
this week and this is gonna serve two
purposes the first is just to provide
content for you guys a lot of you all
really really loved incredible hulks so
I figured I'd just do like a lot of
incredible hoax stuff specifically we're
gonna be covering the entirety of the
Planet Hulk event the other half of this
is to see whether or not you guys were
watching Hulk videos because you just
wanted to see him kill the superheroes
if you guys are genuinely interested in
everything involving the Hulk if you
only cared about the origin of a son
it's really just a test to see what
people are interested in what they're
not interested in how many of you guys
will watch the entire Planet Hulk versus
just one single video it's really just
kind of an experiment on my part you
guys are my guinea pigs so I'm really
just kind of experimenting here but for
those of you guys who saw the Planet
Hulk animated series or who have looked
up the story online or something like
that
the first volume I'm really like exile
it's kind of like the main story like
that's the main Planet Hulk thing where
he becomes a gladiator and he goes
against the Silver Surfer that's the
kind of thing we'll be covering here in
this video the things that follow after
that are all the it's like one giant
prologue really that sets the stage for
the world war hulk event for him coming
back to earth um a lot of the stuff that
we'll talk about in the prologue is
really what's discussed during the
guests during our videos on the origin
of the Incredible Hulk son of the origin
of scar now to lead into this proper to
really get a I guess a firm grasp of
what's going on um there was a prelude
to this but the prelude is not really
necessary the only thing we need to know
is that there was a conflict whereby
Bruce Banner had transformed into Joe
fixa that's his gray form of the
Incredible Hulk and he had gone on a
rampage in Las Vegas and the result was
that he did go against Ben Grimm uh he
did go against a few superheroes here
and there and where is it you know those
individuals had tried to bring him back
the problem with this was that after the
event was finished the Fantastic Four
and really the earth superheroes had
come to the realization that the
Incredible Hulk was just too impulsive
he was just too unpredictable to control
now this was a decision that was largely
made by the Illuminati now Marvel Comics
in terms of chronology the Illuminati or
I guess in terms of publication history
rather the Illuminati are relatively new
they were a creation by Brian
michael bendis i think and they were a
new introduction but it was a retcon a
retroactive continuity meaning that
Brian Michael Bendis created the
Illuminati and then wrote their stories
in a way so that they had been here the
entire time they have been in existence
since the early days of Marvel Comics
and chronologically they date all the
way back to the kree-skrull war now we
don't need to get into the depths of the
kree-skrull war but suffice it to say
they're two alien races that have been
fighting for millions and millions of
years and their conflict had eventually
come close to the planet Earth and
because it stretched the planet Earth
because it almost impacted the earth the
decision was made by Reed Richards by
dr. strange black hole of the Inhumans
Charles Xavier Iron Man Tony Stark to
basically form a group among themselves
to safeguard the planet Earth and they
would basically operate in secret nobody
would know that they existed the idea
was that they would basically protect
the earth from any threat that they
found that was either you know from
beyond the earth or within the earth
itself now the kicker to all this is
that in original sin we learn Nick Fury
had already been doing this Nick Fury
was the man on the wall the way these
two things reconcile is that they didn't
know about each other at the very least
Nick Fury knew about these Illuminati
but chose not to do anything but the
Illuminati did not know that Nick Fury
was the man on the wall so this really
shows how secretive Nick Fury was but
the idea of the Illuminati was to
basically trick I the Incredible Hulk
Nick Fury went to him with a scenario
saying well in the Cold War there was a
satellite that was launched by the
Russians it was supposed to be a spy
satellite Hydra had basically taken
control of it they had installed an
artificial intelligence that AI began to
evolve over the course of the last you
know 50 years or however long it's been
and eventually it took over the the
satellite the issue with this was that
the satellite was designed for the
purpose to detonate nuclear missiles and
so if this satellites not destroyed a
Hydra can use it to detonate on nuclear
weapons anywhere in the world and
potentially lead to a worldwide crisis
and really the extinction of humanity
and so what they did is they went to
banner and said hey we need you to
become the Incredible Hulk we need you
to go to the satellite we need you to
destroy it and then come back the kicker
was that once he got up there while he
did fight this artificial intelligence
the entire situation turned out to be a
ruse the Illuminati tricked him onto the
ship with the intention of sending him
off to the far side of the galaxy
away from the planet Earth now we'll
learn a little bit more about what their
plan was but what Greg Pak did with us
is he just immediately picked up with
the conflict he immediately picked up
with the incredible
survival now and The Incredible Hulk
ended up landing on a planet called
Sekar now as we know from our story of
the origin of the Incredible Hulk son
the story of Skaar we learned that these
portals were created by an existing
inhabitant on Sekar for the purpose of
bringing individuals to the planet that
could basically cast off the ruling body
of the Red King they could cast them off
from all their threats and allow the
people to live in freedom and so this is
why the Incredible Hulk fell through
this portal it had already been
generated and he just ended up deviating
into it just because of the fact that it
had a gravitational pull but once he
arrives
of course the Incredible Hulk does what
the Incredible Hulk does he just starts
tearing stuff up this is why I love The
Incredible Hulk in this story is it's
like it's like this it's like you just
radiates power you know and it's like
this hidden power that no one really
seems to grasp I don't know about you
guys but I love that concept I love that
ideology that feeling when there's like
a being present in a story and no one
realizes how powerful they are and
you're just waiting like heroes you're
just waiting for like you're just
waiting for [ __ ] to pop off basically
for things to just hit the fan and it's
like now everybody realizes how powerful
he is and people are like oh my god
these powerful like like this that's the
kind of thing I love in comic books
absolutely I adore that idea hopefully
you guys do too but when he arrives here
of course he ends up going against the
indigenous species and there really
isn't much of a conflict here between
those guys and himself but after he
arrives here he's also set upon by the
imperial guard of the Red King and like
all individuals who crash-landed on this
planet he is bound with an obedience
disk now we're gonna go ahead and cheat
a little bit on under normal
circumstances we would wait until that
part of the story to get into it but we
can go ahead and cheat here and cover
this a little bit the obedience disk is
a device that's planted on an individual
and it quite literally interfaces with
their brain not in the sense of mind
control but in the sense that they're
basically bound to follow the obedience
disk by fear of pain and if they if they
fight against the obedience disk too
long it'll basically fry their brain
it'll destroy every ounce of what makes
them who they are and it'll just turn
them into a mindless walking being we'll
actually see what happens with a few
heroes or a few characters but when they
fought the obedience disk too hard but
almost immediately after Hulk is bound
with this disk he's taken to this sort
of auction house to these gladiatorial
games now what
pack does here is he basically takes the
traditional idea of Roman society and
gladiator games and folds them over into
this now for those of you guys who don't
know and I wouldn't call myself a
history buff when it comes to the
gladiatorial games in realm but I think
I know enough that I can make a
convincing explanation who are a
reasonable explanation here um the
gladiatorial games existed in two forms
one as a source of entertainment and two
as a way to distract the Roman people
from the problems of Roman society but
the gladiatorial games were a huge event
I mean it was a massive thing it was
like it was like if the entire United
States became involved in the Super Bowl
like everybody went to the Super Bowl
like that's what the gladiatorial games
were like and it was just some of the
best fighters from across all of Rome in
all of its different territories but it
wasn't like every single fighter just
went to the gladiatorial games you had
to work your way up you had to start at
the bottom at local gladiator
competitions and then work your way to
the very top to be in a gladiatorial
games so again it's much like the Super
Bowl in the sense that you've got the
regular-season then you've got the
postseason and so when it comes to the
Incredible Hulk here of course you know
when he's initially displayed before the
Red King the red King's not really too
surprised by what he sees in terms of
just the Hulk breaking out of his out of
his [ __ ] but what does impress the Red
King is the ruthlessness of the Hulk now
right now at this moment this is not
world break or Hulk I mean you know
Bruce Banner is mad you know banners
pissed he's very very angry but he's
nowhere near the level that he will be
with with world war hulk it's insane how
powerful he is during world war hulk but
the very gist of this is that upon his
initial arrival he basically just starts
taking - and and ripping up these
various foes that go against him now he
also encounters meek for the very first
time now meek will become a very
important character with regards to the
Planet Hulk mythos but you know once
Banner basically begins to realize
what's going on once he you know
realizes that he's basically in a
gladiatorial game
you know once meek basically says hey
you know we're fighting for the
enjoyment of the Red King and we're
fighting for the enjoyment of the people
he realizes the Red King is the one
that's running the show here and so
Hulk's initial reaction is alright let's
kill the Red King let's call it a day
and then I can find a way to go home but
the red Kingsguard Kyra immediately
steps in now as we know she's going to
be a major figure in the post exile
landscape for the Planet Hulk event but
in this immediate moment right here
she's basically just the guard she's
basically like the top guy
hard for the Red King himself now there
is a lot of history between the two of
them but initially the Red King says no
no no do not take him out I will fight
the Incredible Hulk myself this is cool
to me because the Red King had no idea
what he was going against he didn't know
the savagery of the Hulk he didn't know
the strength of the Hulk and this proves
itself in the sense that when the two go
head-to-head the o Banner takes the
sword and just slashes the Red King
across the face now this is an offense
that would usually guarantee death just
because of the fact that whenever you
deal with any monarchy in history if
anyone ever assaults the ruling person
or the ruling family they're almost
immediately killed but for the Red King
himself he also realizes the benefit
that would come with the Incredible Hulk
in the sense that if the Hulk is allowed
to fight the whole can draw a lot of
people in the hoping keep a lot of
people distracted from the main war and
the main rebellion the Red King has
going on here as well as the other plans
that he has taking place in the
background of course we'll learn more
about that but the idea here is that
when the Hulk's guard is basically down
you know he's suddenly attacked from
behind by the Red King his Kyra tries to
take him out and the Red King
celebration so this is actually really
important because what this does is this
lays the groundwork for the relationship
between Kyra and The Incredible Hulk in
the sense that neo and when she says
this is not your planet he says well not
yet and as a person who's extremely
honorable whose honor bound to the Red
King himself the Kyra is also a warrior
at heart and she realizes it recognizes
another warrior as well and so I
wouldn't go as far as to say that the
two have immediately fallen in love I
will say that with gray pack the
progress towards the two of them falling
in love is basically beginning with this
first encounter now from here we
sidetrack for a second and we actually
pick up with some highborn or at least
people who are part of a part of the
Imperial race that rules a planet and
when it comes to Sekar you have like an
imperial race but not everybody is
Imperial in the sense that they do not
have the same rights and privileges as
the existing Red King or any of his
immediate surroundings those individuals
that are part of his inner circle the
reason behind this is because some of
these individuals do not believe in the
Red King and they basically operate as
rebels now with the arrival of the
Incredible Hulk they look at him as the
sac arson the son of Sekar the man that
is supposed to come to the planet and
liberate them of their oppression and so
the idea here is for them to basically
grab the Incredible Hulk heaven
on their behalf become part of the
rebellion and cast off the Red King now
from here we transition to a place
called the MA now the MA initially came
off as a prison that was my first
thought when I saw it but the MA is
actually like a proving ground it is a
training ground for those individuals
who are going to be part of the
gladiatorial games and this is what I
say the Red King didn't immediately have
the Incredible Hulk killed granted and
he was hoping the Incredible Hulk would
die here at the mall but the idea was
that you know if he survives and he'll
go on to become part of the gladiatorial
games now the guy who's basically
running the show here was a former
member of the gladiatorial games he was
a guy that fought in the gladiatorial
games and worked his way to freedom and
the way this is done is you basically
fight all the way to the top you win
three rounds and then you're pardoned by
the Red King that's why this exists the
way it does because they're literally
all fighting for their own individual
freedom now while this happens or at
least while they're in this mom they're
basically pit against one another as
well as some various forces that happen
to be around there and it's really just
thinning the herd I mean that that's
that's really all Greg Pak is doing here
Greg patch is saying hey there's like
this huge population of prisoners in the
MOC they're all gonna fight each other
and then you know whoever's left
whoever's left alive are gonna be the
ones that basically become like the
gladiator team and this is what happened
we basically have like you know this war
bound being formed we have the
Incredible Hulk we have chord we have
meek we have Loa and a few others we
have here om we have basically these
guys that come together as the last
surviving seven now the kicker to this
is that they're not technically war
bound yet within the realm of a Planet
Hulk event war bound is a practice made
among warriors those individuals that
would fight for one another to the death
in order to make sure that you know if
they do die they die well they die with
honor they would never sacrifice each
other they would never give up on one
another they they basically hold the
closest of allegiances now this again is
going to be a very important thing with
World War Hulk because a lot of these
guys actually traveled back with him
toward war Hulk but this is really just
you know initially all of them sitting
down and saying hey guys let's have this
big powwow let's tell our stories and
let's you know let's make s'mores and I
love s'mores like listen I get so
distracted so he's a hashtag a DD so um
they're basically always kind of like
hanging out there they're telling their
own individual stories this is Greg pack
basically saying the Hulk does not
consider himself to be a regular guy
here now
is actually really cool for the
evolution of his character because for
Bruce Banner being on this planet all
he's doing is just biding his time until
he leaves it's much like you saw with
the animated series there are some big
differences but this is one of the
similarities in the sense that Banner
does not see himself as a guy that's
gonna be here for the long haul he
doesn't see himself as a guy that used
to form alliances you know he's just
kind of like hey look we'll fight
together if we have to but when it comes
down to it if you guys die I don't care
I just want to get off this planet and
so what we do is we basically pick up
with day two now day two you gives us
the the former allies of pork the crazy
thing about this is that Korg is one of
several individuals who had basically
arrived on the planet forced here by one
of those portals well he basically
operated as a man of his own individual
will so to speak the other people that
were alongside him basically fought
against their obedience disks and
because of this their brains were
essentially fried now when we saw in
Planet Hulk animated thing this was part
of the main gladiatorial games in the
story that's not the case they're still
in training basically they're still in
the MA
itself and so you know we're core does
not initially want to find his allies
the Incredible Hulk says hey man get it
together you know either you're going to
fight here or you're going to die here
you know these guys are mindless they're
not your friends anymore as far as
you're concerned they're just dudes here
that are in the way of you getting your
freedom and so because of this Korg is
basically able to pull it together and
they officially become the 18 they're
there basically I guess team a is kind
of what they refer to you but they prove
themselves in the Maul and so at this
point it's really just small-time
gladiatorial games it's really just
small-time things you know it's it's
small bits here and there where they
basically prove their worth as capable
fighters and they successfully do that
you know they're able to prove their
worth they're able to show that when it
comes down to it they have exactly what
it takes to be legitimate gladiators the
other half of this is that the Red King
is met with a conversation over their
communication devices from Kyra she
basically says hey look The Incredible
Hulk has people talking you know up
until this point it's been well maybe
somebody will win maybe they'll die
there's you know it's really been just
more for watching the entertainment of
people but the Incredible Hulk is
inspiring open rebellion and the reason
why is because those rebels who are out
out there on the fence those rebels who
were plotting you know to overthrow the
the Red King we're waiting for their
Savior you know corner unquote to come
and when he did he came in the form of
the Incredible Hulk and so now they're
far more brazen than they have been and
they're taking a lot more risks than
they had been case-in-point
maybe
we break into the cells of the
Incredible Hulk and the other gladiators
they say Hulk come fight for us you know
come come fight on our behalf help us
overthrow the Red King now the funny
thing about this is that hook says no he
says no no no I don't want to have
anything to do with this now hope as we
know by this point has a bigger plan he
has a more grandiose plan but even then
you know despite the fact that this is
hope he's not stupid
he doesn't have the brain of Bruce
Banner but he's still relatively
intelligent at this point and in his
mind he realizes that if they go with
these guys in open rebellion these
rebels are not going to make it these
rebels are not going to survive they're
likely going to be captured or they're
gonna be killed possibly even both but
the best way for the Incredible Hulk to
gain is freedom and to kill the Red King
is to work within the system this is
really kind of cool here because LOA
sides with the rebels and of course
she's taken prisoner by the wild BOTS
and so the idea is well you know maybe
she's gonna be killed maybe she's gonna
be cast out no one really knows now
switching over to one of the other guys
what he basically says is look she's not
going to be a survivor and the reason
why is because every single time a
member of their race is taken by the Red
King they disappear they basically just
vanished into a black bag somewhere and
no one knows where they go to and so
this is really just more of a of a
scenario where we're essentially
learning that the Red King is killing
off anybody that could be legitimate
competition now from here we have Greg
pack basically jumping back to the idea
of tire herself and the romantic tension
between herself and Bruce Banner this is
actually really kind of cool because you
know I wouldn't say again that she's
very much in love but I would say that
she looks at him as something better
than he is she looked at him as
something great but somebody that could
potentially lead into a much better
future not only that she basically says
hey look if you make it out of here
alive I wouldn't mind touching naughty
bits a couple times
ah that's weird but you know that's
that's kind of where her character
stands at the moment so what we do is we
basically pick up with the Incredible
Hulk and his warbound in the Big Time
games and the great big huge deal here
now again you know for this part this is
really just them fighting their way
through the ranks and they're proving to
be capable but this is really just them
fighting their way through the ranks the
issue with this is that these wild BOTS
they're going against are very very
capable in term taking people out a lot
of it being because of the fact that
they won against the the spikes and the
spikes of course will
about here in a little bit that's a
whole different kettle of beans it's
part of this grandiose plan to the Red
King had to basically can't sort of put
himself in power but from here they
actually begin going about telling
legitimate stories about themselves they
really delve more into who they are once
this massive battle is finished and once
they go back to their ranks or go back
to their position as being gladiators
and we learned therefore you know korg
for example he had arrived on earth and
he had basically been challenged by Thor
and Thor had used his hammer and
single-handedly taking them all out we
know with it with Bruce Banner he
actually reveals his backstory to them
tells them everything about himself
again this is really just them kind of
coming together and this is when they
officially form themselves as a warbound
now again with the warbound what this
means is that they are an official
alliance now it means that they will
never give the other up it means that no
matter what happens they will fight
alongside each other and either they
they succeed either they live together
or they die together but they'll never
turn each other in and they'll never
assassinated or do anything to cut the
other now we're gonna find some
complications with this but what we also
learned here is that essentially this
Silver Surfer has been held captive or
been been taken by the Red King and is
being held as their champion in the
gladiatorial ring now the funny thing
about this is the Silver Surfer it just
more or less been pushed into the
situation you're sort of been just fell
through that particular portal and
arrived here was immediately planted
with an obedience disk and so because of
this the Silver Surfer is also bound by
this disc and forced to do the bidding
of the Red King as part of the gladiator
games and so this really leads us to
this idea that the Incredible Hulk and
his warbound
are basically at the top they're on the
cusp of reaching their freedom all they
have to do is defeat the reign champion
this silver surfer now when the surfer
appears here no one else knows who he is
they don't know the significance of the
Silver Surfer now this is kind of ironic
because for almost every organized
civilization where the Silver Surfer
appears Galactus is soon to follow
Galactus is not far behind that's why
whatever a lot of societies see the
Silver Surfer they immediately panic and
they just bail out they just they just
jump in their ships and they vacate the
planet because they know this is likely
due to the fact that Galactus is coming
to consume their planet the fact that
these guys don't know this is kind of
ironic in addition to this the Silver
Surfer if it wasn't planted with
disobedience disk would just immediately
obliterate all the forces here he would
basically annihilate every single last
one of them but the Incredible Hulk
knows who the Silver Surfer is now
actually goes all the way back to the
days of dr. Strange's defenders when the
Incredible Hulk and the Silver Surfer
fought side-by-side as allies and so
it's not like the incredible folks like
hey I recognize that guy I've seen him
before it's I have fought alongside that
guy you know I know who that guy is he's
a Silver Surfer you know if anybody can
give us our freedom it's him now the
Silver Surfer of course because he's
bound by this obedience disk immediately
attached The Incredible Hulk
you know and this is kind of funny
because Banner says well you're just
like all of them now this again shows us
the psychotic state of Bruce Banner the
fact that he's really more irrational
than anything else because remember in
his heart of hearts right now he's
swearing vengeance against the
Illuminati right now he's just mad you
know right now he's just angry like they
screwed me over they cheated me you know
I'll get revenge on them at some point
along the line now we'll learn that the
plan of Bruce Banner actually changes
the Oh after the events that are getting
ready to happen here but in his mind
he's still angry at the Illuminati
because he feels like he's been tricked
what's happening right here this small
scene with the Silver Surfer attacking
The Incredible Hulk
this is the story of his life The
Incredible Hulk makes friends the
friends of Incredible Hulk turn on him
and then the Incredible Hulk goes into
hiding and refuses to trust those
friends again
except you replace those friends with
humanity and a multitude of heroes and
it's the Hulk's life over and over and
over again now a lot of times this is
due to the fact that the Hulk just
didn't understand what was going on
didn't grasp the full context of the
situation but in his mind right now you
know he's like the Silver Surfer is
attacking me the silver surfers just
like everybody else and so because of
this he immediately takes it to the
Silver Surfer now this is kind of cool
here because what Greg Pak is telling us
is that one on one when it comes to
sheer strength the unbridled strength to
the Incredible Hulk is dominant over the
Silver Surfer but the other half of this
is we also have to kind of ask the
question if the Silver Surfer wanted to
could he take out the Incredible Hulk
the answer to that question is
unequivocally yes now if it's world war
hulk that poses a different question
because what we're hope is very very
capable in terms of his durability his
strength but it requires that he gets
his hands on the Silver Surfer so the
Silver Surfer Gerdes kind of you know
stay out of arms reach and just
constantly bombard him with cosmic
energy and eventually if the incredible
hope would probably be killed but at the
very least in this in the context of
this situation The Incredible Hulk is
just lashing I mean just tearing into
the Silver Surfer now this is about as
close as he gets to world break or Hulk
during the planet hooker
this is about as close as he gets to
being as strong as he was during the
World War Hulk event but it's also kind
of ironic here because the more he loses
it and the more that he pummels the
Silver Surfer the more terrified people
become because of how powerful he is and
the reason why is because the only
context that these viewers these these
citizens have had with regards to the
strength of the Silver Surfer is the
fact that he's beaten everybody up to
this point and so the Incredible Hulk
rising up to this level no one ever had
any idea of just how strong he was but
the fact that he's able to beat the
reigning champion into submission and
into the extreme is mind-blowing and so
because of the fact that the Silver
Surfer is essentially defeated the
warbound and the Incredible Hulk say
look we've we played your game we won
your game give us our freedom but what
happens is Kyra basically uses the
instance of the Incredible Hulk slash in
the face of the Red King to say okay you
have one final test and your final test
is to kill Loa and the other rebels who
tried to stand against the Red King now
the kicker to this is that Kyra kind of
knows how this is gonna play out to a
degree she knows that there are members
of the warbound who are not going to
kill Loa they don't want to kill one of
their own even if Ella way had walked
out they still have honor for her as an
honorable fighter and so they refuse to
kill her in response to this the idea is
either you kill her or you're going back
and you're gonna be in the gladiatorial
games until you do they would literally
just keep her around keep her alive
until the Incredible Hulk in his
warbound were willing to kill her
otherwise they would just stay in the
gladiatorial games but in response to
this because of the fact that the
Incredible Hulk had destroyed the
obedience disk of the Silver Surfer
and no one had noticed the Silver Surfer
uses his power cosmic to destroy the
obedience discs on the chest of every
body in the entire kingdom this is kind
of the kicker because what this tells us
is this is how the red King's been
maintaining his power the Red King has
not been maintaining his power through
loyalty he's been maintaining his power
through force now there there are
individuals like higher you know who do
not have obedience discs planted on her
just because of the fact that she does
willingly swear absolute allegiance to
him because she's honour bound to do so
we'll find out why later on but the gist
behind this is with all these people
free the question is what do we do now I
mean we have freedom like what do we do
and the Incredible Hulk says where we do
the only thing that makes sense we just
start ripping [ __ ] off
does you know he alongside the other
guys tear down the gladiatorial stadium
and they basically say we're free let's
go they basically walk away now
initially the Silver Surfer says hey man
if you want I can take you back to earth
and The Incredible Hulk says no I'm
staying here I've basically found a
place that I can call my own because the
Incredible Hulk looks at the world that
he's in right now he looks at the
situation they said and he says hey look
I can basically form a life for myself
you know if those guys on earth don't
trust me you know then fine I'll just
stay here and I'll make this world mine
you know I will operate outside of them
I have followers I have people who trust
me people who were honorbound to me The
Incredible Hulk has found more loyalty
here on Sekar than he's ever found over
the course of his life on earth and so
for him there's no reason to go back I
am NOT a patient man I've never been a
patient man I've never had patients from
the time that I was a little kid up
until right now when I want something I
don't want it now I want it right now
like I don't I don't like waiting I hate
waiting on things and I've been reading
through Planet Hulk and I was like hmm I
can't wait to do World War Hulk sounds
like you know we're gonna do we're gonna
cover like everything in this video on
Planet hope we're gonna cover all the
rest of the stuff that way we can jump
into World War Hulk because World War
Hawk is stupidly good it is it's insane
how good it is so following the events
of our first video really like the first
volume the plan hook of end really began
- it was really Greg Pak taking this
traditional standard on a multi-part
series in the sense that um you really
had like in the beginning you basically
have the stage being set that's usually
how the first story arc goes it sets the
stage it says hey here's the status quo
and then there will be some kind of
major conflict and what that conflict
will do is it will eliminate the
existing status quo and it'll begin a
transition to the new status quo and
that's exactly what happened in our
first video you know to kind of provide
a little bit of a refresher there for
the first video it was really just the
Incredible Hulk being sent away from the
planet Earth by the Illuminati because
he was deemed too unpredictable he
crashed landed on Sekar he was basically
press-ganged into the gladiatorial games
and then eventually rose up against the
Red King alongside the Silver Surfer now
the kicker about all this is that
following the Incredible Hulk
essentially defeating the immediate
armies of the red
and going out into saqar proper he of
course had his warbound cord in Alloway
and so on but the idea was that his
actions had inspired open rebellion
among everybody else like all these
slaves from across the planet who were
subservient to the Red King had looked
to the Incredible Hulk as an example of
the fact that they could attain their
own freedom whether it was through force
or otherwise and so in response to this
the Red King did the only thing he knew
how to do the Red King used force in
order to try to maintain his control now
the cool thing about all this was that
kyra his shadow a member of the old
strong didn't really know the full
spectrum of everything that had been
going on instead from her mind she was a
child being groomed to understand how
the old power worked ought to be great
being groomed to understand what her
place was going to be as a warrior among
her own group the issue with this was
that at some point along the line was
she was a young girl the spikes
had suddenly attacked her village and it
resulted in the Red King basically you
know allowing the conflict to take place
and then turning around and finding out
who she was and then taking her as his
own now what Greg Pak is doing here is
Greg Pak is using a really cool instance
of something called game theory and it
works out really really well with
regards to this story so game theory is
is literally just using like
mathematical probability to determine
the logical action that people will take
a really good example of this ruckus and
this particular instance he's using
something as like a leader so um to
sidetrack for a second and bear with me
here because this may seem kind of out
of left field but let's say that like
you're the leader of a territory right
let's say you're like the leader of the
United States of whatever your name is
the United States of comics explain
let's say you're the leader of the
United States of Commerce explain and
you learn that another country is going
to attack you well you have three
options are available to you you can let
the attack happen
you can stop the attack beforehand or
you can attack them before they attack
you now the idea here is under normal
circumstances to attack them before they
attack you or defend against the attack
make preparations to keep your people
safe but if you did either of those it
would alert the enemy to what it is that
you're doing and so what you can do is
you can let the attack happen and then
in turn your people will rally under you
it's it's one of the concepts of game
theory but the idea here is that the Red
King did exactly that the Red King had a
motive here the Red King was a child he
was an emperor he wasn't really viewed
as being someone that could be an effect
leader and so what he needed was someone
at his side that could basically
maintain the level of protection that he
needed but could also allow him to a
half others look to him as a legitimate
leader and by going to one of the oldest
races in the entirety of sukar's history
and essentially allowing an attack on
their group to happen and then turning
around and capturing the strongest of
them it forged an allegiance by force as
opposed to you know diplomacy or
something like that but the basis behind
this entire revelation who was that Kyra
had learned that the spikes were
implemented by the Red King himself it
was until the spiked system we just
arrived in her village and attacked her
this has been orchestrated by the Red
King now something else to point out
here is the Red King did not engineer
the spikes instead within the Marvel
Universe the spice existed as basically
like a sentient organism and they
literally just fed on cosmic energy they
would just traverse the spaceways and
they would feed on energy the problem
with this was that during the rule of
the red King's father the spikes had
landed and then were eventually
eliminated or removed from the planet by
the red King's father they were
essentially sent to the moon the problem
with this is that while they stayed in
stasis for some time and they ended up
turning to cannibalism in order to
survive the Red King harnessed the
spikes for his own uses and the Red King
basically used the spikes to essentially
get rid of communities that had worked
against him to get rid of communities
that were not functioning the way that
he wanted them to or not recognizing his
rule as being legitimate but in learning
about this akai era had effectively
turned against the Red King she had
turned against him realizing that he was
not an ally that he was an enemy now the
lights that he was willing to go to to
try to defeat those who were standing
against him was a such an extreme that
he was actually willing to wipe out all
life on the planet if it meant that
nobody would challenge him and so
because of this because of the fact that
he was so extreme because he was so
dangerous because of the fact that he
had basically destroyed her people
kierra had turned against the Red King
and allied herself with the Incredible
Hulk and so what happened is Kyra
alongside the Hulk as well as the
remnants of the warbound
basically went through and cut a swath
and I know you guys I know you guys when
I say that kind of swath through the
entirety of the red King's army
eventually leading to his defeat now in
this original story the way Greg pack
did it was presumed that the Red King
had been killed but of course as we
learned with regards to the the origin
of scar himself as The Incredible Hulk
son now the Red King didn't die the Red
King and said was basically beaten to
the
of death and then eventually brought
back by his own wild BOTS but what the
story does what these have been to do is
they effectively pick up with the
Incredible Hulk alongside Kiera
essentially creating their own way and
informing their own Kingdom and the
remnants of the Red Kings rule now the
funny thing about this is with the
Incredible Hulk and Kyra they're almost
one in the same in terms of how they
view things in a sense that care has
been raised to be a warrior and so she's
the very definition of a warrior in
truth she's really more akin to Thor
than anybody else but in the confines of
this particular story um she wants peace
to a degree but she's also Anil has no
qualms killing those that get in her way
and The Incredible Hulk is the exact
same way but the other half of this coin
is that when the Incredible Hulk first
showed up on Sekar as part of the Planet
Hulk event he wanted to leave he didn't
want to have anything to do with these
guys here he didn't want to have
anything to do with forming a war bound
or basically leading the inhabitants to
salvation but the way this worked is
that he was viewed as essentially being
thus a Carson that is to say basically
the savior of Sekar whenever he bled it
ended up growing plants on the surface
and so it really allowed these
civilizations that were here to look at
him as quite literally their messianic
figure a guy that was going to lead them
into a much greater tomorrow now
eventually the Incredible Hulk actually
takes this role on alongside with higher
and he basically looks at himself as a
king with her as his queen more so than
that he's also met with meek now the
cool thing about this when it comes to
Meeks character is he basically helps
some of his people who have been held
captive to escape into freedom but in
the process had actually undergone this
transformation basically making him the
king and allowing him to get with their
queen and do what they do in order to
create offspring um the Queen's not much
to look at but it works within the
confines of their own race here but the
other half of this is that they're very
much in the middle of cleaning up here
they're very much in the middle of
getting everything sorted out now with
regards to the conversation between the
incredible Hogan Kyra this is why I say
it's such an important part of his
character is because when he takes her
and they go on somewhat of a journey
where they go to basically like the
steps of Sekar which is this sort of
proving ground slash you know peaceful a
harmonic place the two of them begin to
talk and The Incredible Hulk says that
all he was bred for is destruction I
mean when when the incredible hole
existed on earth all he did was just
destroy things now
again a lot of this was because the
Incredible Hulk wanted to be left alone
but it didn't change the fact that the
Incredible Hulk always was destructive
by nature hits the reason he was sent
away by the Illuminati whenever he looks
at the entire history of his time on
Sekar he looks at the events ads they've
unfolded throughout the entire Planet
Hulk event all he sees is a continuation
of the pattern that he had on earth in
that wherever he goes destruction will
follow him but kyra looks at him and
says this is not the case when you bleed
it grows plant life and look at the life
that you've created he's basically
restore the planet he's in the process
of terraforming the planet just because
of his blood and so what he's done is
he's given all the civilizations on
Sekar hope he's given them a future to
look forward to and because of this his
life while on earth he may very well
have been a force of destruction on
Sekar he's a savior in every ounce of
the word now this is huge for the
Incredible Hulk and this is why Greg
packs writing a Planet Hulk is so good
because we've never really seen an
instance like this as one of reasons why
I love The Incredible Hulk we'd never
seen him written in such a way to where
he was more of a savior than a destroyer
now a lot of that was because of the
fact that you know within the confines
of his role on earth he was just kind of
a bumbling buffoon that was it was he
was a bull in a china shop there's
really the best way to describe the
Incredible Hulk on earth and it worked
in a lot of situations because we have
to see him go against some various you
know heroes and you know even more so
with villains it was kind of like well
if things aren't going our way calling
the whole kill solve our problem then
we'll send him away it was it was really
interesting in how it was done but it
didn't add a lot of character depth the
most stuff we ever really got it was
during Peter David's run when it came to
the incredible hoax history his abusive
father so on and so forth and why the
whole persona manifested when banner was
blasted with gamma rays but that was
about it there was really no huge
exploration into his character the cool
thing about this though is that we get
that in this story we get so much depth
with regards to the Incredible Hulk the
I guess to such an extreme that he
actually changes his tune you know he
tells Kyra yeah you're right you know I
am a savior here I am a person here that
can literally lead all these different
races to a much better tomorrow and so
he along side higher and everybody else
here begins the process of cleaning up
begins the process of getting things
sorted out now what we also learned is
that there is some trouble in paradise
you know there are individuals that look
at the Incredible Hulk Loa especially
and says he's not that
different from the Red King the Red King
used us as slaves to build his kingdom
and it seems like the incredible Hawks
doing the same thing now we as the
reader know this is not the case all we
know is that the Incredible Hulk is just
making them apply a little bit of elbow
grease and that it's really one of these
situations where everybody has to chip
in in order to make everything better
you know it's not something where the
Incredible Hulk can just fix everything
more so than that there's a reward to
this you know once they finish
rebuilding once they finish clearing all
this debris out once they finish
restructuring and making the kingdom
their own they can sit back at their
handiwork and say this is ours
you know something earned is far more
significant than something given and so
the idea here is that they're
effectively earning their place in this
kingdom they're earning the right to say
we made this as opposed to well we just
topple the red King everything stayed
intact and then we just occupied the
kingdom it really establishes them as
being part and parcel into this entire
area itself and so from here we really
have this kind of conclusion with
regards to the idea of the spikes and
it's really just kind of highs and it's
really just Greg Pak you know
eliminating these last few things in the
sense that these various spike ships
that have been confined to the moon that
hadn't quite been harnessed by the Red
King which ultimately led to the
Incredible Hulk traveling to the moon
and freeing all the spikes and allowing
them to go back about their business not
traversing the spaceways and so it's
literally just kind of him fulfilling
these last few packs fulfilling these
last few agreements
you know solidifying the fact that the
Incredible Hulk is a true legitimate and
benign leader over the people in in
Sekar the problem with this is that as
they begin to celebrate once everything
begins to get put together you know once
everything begins to come back to normal
we suddenly find that this is the ship
of the shuttle that the Incredible Hulk
had been brought in begins to start
beeping now the idea was to turn this
shuttle into somewhat of a monument to
basically make it a testament to the
fact that the Incredible Hulk had been
sent here as a sacar s'en he had
liberated them all and ushered them in
the freedom and because of the fact that
this thing starts to beeping we
basically learned that this is a warp
core meltdown that the nuclear core of
this ship is beginning to break down is
beginning to detonate and so the
incredible hope does what he can to try
to protect those around him you know
especially Kyra who's currently pregnant
with her child but the result is that
there's really nothing he can do this
nuclear powered really bombed for lack
of a better word essentially explodes
and it destroys everything in the Crown
City everything and almost everyone the
only people who aren't killed here are
those individuals those people who
part of his warbound here om korg those
people who basically sent away from the
crown city in order to begin the process
of creating diplomatic ties with other
civilizations other tribes around the
planet in order to ensure that they you
know that they don't really recognize
the incredible hulk as their king so
much as they see him as the new ruler of
crown city and someone with which they
can have diplomatic relations with and
so because they're not currently present
they become aware of what's going on
they realize that the crown city has
been destroyed in a nuclear blast but
for them they don't know why they don't
really understand why but the more
important thing about this it's greg pak
is setting the stage here with the
incredible hulk as a character and this
this is one of the reasons why i loved
the the end of Planet Hulk so much
because as this one I say there's so
much development with the Incredible
Hulk as a character all he's known is
disappointment I mean that's the story
of his life let down after let down
superheroes claim to be his friends and
then they betray him villains use him
for their own ends humanity's constantly
hunting him down the incredible Hawks
life was just nothing but a sad tale you
know Bruce banners father was an
extremely abusive man's you know more so
to the point that is believed that bruce
banner himself develop multiple
personalities and so when he was blasted
with the gamma bomb that led to the
formation of the incredible hulk the
incredible hulk is just the physical
manifestation of his anger towards his
father his rage against humanity you
know his hatred against all things or
anything that would try to do harm
against banner himself it's really like
a physical manifestation of a
psychological desire to stay protected
from everything in the world that would
harm him and so the idea is that leaving
earth and being sent on Sekar for the
first time gave the Incredible Hulk
purpose it gave him a place that he
believed he can call his own and the
incredible work says this you know he
says look when I was here I thought I
had a place I I believed this could be
something real I believed it could be
something true I believed that I could
really look out onto the horizon of a
Rising Sun and see a better tomorrow but
he says I was foolish to believe this I
was foolish to believe that I would find
anything but death and destruction
everywhere I go now as we know with our
origin story of scar this was the moment
where by kyra had basically sent her
unborn son into the planet in order to
basically be saved from the presumed
destruction of sakaar
and he would essentially emerge and so
these last few moments of the Incredible
Hulk
planet or around the time that his son
is emerging and beginning to come into
his own in terms of encountering these
various species and so on that are part
of the planet itself part of the
indigenous life but then suddenly the
Incredible Hulk is also met with the
remainder of his warbound with court
hero in meek so on and initially the
incredible hope wants to be left alone
because he's quite literally a grieving
guy here but as we know with the stages
of grief at first its denial
its denial of the fact that those
individuals around that we lose are dead
it's the idea well don't you know
somehow something will happen things
will change we can get things back to
the way they were before after that it
leads to anger and this is the
Incredible Hulk angry but this is him
about as mad as he's ever going to be
and so he alongside with his warbound
prepare they prepare for an invasion of
Earth they begin the process of forming
arms and armament for full-on invasion
and destruction of those who did the
Incredible Hulk harm and so in effect at
the beginning of World War Hulk
the end of the Planet Hulk storyline
what we have here is Bruce Banner with
the wrath of God it is dude I almost
want to just like crank out wood we're
hope right now like oh like this this is
man this is oh can you guys see let's
can you feel the excitement like this is
this I love this story so much because
really Planet Hulk is just like one
giant prelude to world war hulk but at
the same time like and I was in The
Incredible Hulk corner the entire event
I mean let's let's have this a little
bit of a discussion about what war hold
for a second I was in The Incredible
Hulk corner with regards to World War
Hulk I was in his side because I was
like yeah man like humanity's done
nothing but dick you over Incredible
Hulk let's get some revenge dude let's
kill some folks let's go ahead and
remind humanity of their place in their
bigger picture like let's remind them
where they stand because it's not on an
even playing field with you man like I
was I was like let's do this but uh
because I'm so hyped we're gonna go
ahead and cover World War Hulk in the
next video we'll go ahead and kick off
world world but uh but yeah guys like I
really hope you all enjoy this Planet
Hulk series so far um there are a few
things here and there that we didn't
really cover I know there's gonna be
some people who want some of us
we may or may not do that a future point
in time but in truth it wasn't really
relevant to the story per se um it was
really just something we could kind of
gloss over and then get to the meat and
potatoes of planetfall
okay like I don't think the stuff that
we ran over in this video was far more
significant in terms of the development
of the halt because again my aim here
was to basically show you guys the
evolution of Bruce Banner from being
sent to earth residing on Planet Hulk
the things he gained and then interned
lost and why he's so angry and why he
ends up coming back to earth and
literally waging a one-man war against
the superheroes of the planet members of
the Rob core we are here world war hulk
now I got to admit I was kind of on the
fence about this I was like do I really
want to do what where Hulk I mean this
is before I even launched the Planet
Hulk thing because I've been
experimenting with like Red Hulk and
that kind of thing and a lot of guys
really really seemed to enjoy it so I
figured why not just kind of go back
from the beginning from basically Planet
Hulk and move forward up through the
chronology leading us into Red Hook so
here's what we're gonna do for the rest
of this week really until we finished
the world war hulk event which should
probably take us about a week or so it
should take the rest of this week anyway
going into like Saturday what war Hulk
is gonna take the place of everything
except DC rebirth so we're gonna keep
all the DC we worth stuff but like a
classic Marvel classic DC well I think
we might keep classic DC and do like
speeding bullets or something like that
where Superman becomes Batman aside from
that like you know how to kill
superheroes things like that the all-new
all-different marvel day that's all
that's gonna be World War Hulk because
it'll give us a chance to get caught up
really really fast and then turn around
and go back to doing one whole video a
week you know leading up to the launch
of Hulk and all-new all-different marvel
so anyway ah so what we're Hulk is kind
of like this coup de Gras right it's
like it's the magnum opus it's the the
final event of Greg packs run on the
Incredible Hulk and we know that because
after World War Hulk was over it was
essentially Hercules taking up the
mantle of incredible whole boroughs
really just like it was like The
Incredible Hercules Hercules being put
into the wall there would no only be
played by the Incredible Hulk and that
was done just because of the fact that
Hercules just never really had a place
in Marvel Comics and so if model is
doing the best they could to give him a
place to stay the issue is that it
didn't last very long a lot of people
didn't really like it too much and have
some cool stories like chaos war which
is insanely awesome but aside from that
there wasn't really a whole lot to go
with their but what were Hulk initially
opens up with the North American
Aerospace Defense Command outpost which
is actually in Cheyenne and this is
really cool because of course when we
when we had our our planet Hulk of in
our Planet Hulk story at the conclusion
of that we had talked about how the
Incredible Hulk had taken a ship with
his warbound and basically moved or made
it's made its way towards the planet
Earth and this is them essentially just
realizing that the incredible holders
coming now initially they don't know if
the Incredible Hulk instead they just
know that is ship now the issue with
this is that it begs a lot of questions
with regards to you know how people
don't know it's The Incredible Hulk for
example and Marvel Comics they have an
organization called sword the sentient
world observation and response
department and this is literally just an
organization that monitors other worlds
now because of monitors other worlds for
potential threats it may not have just
it just so we made out of register the
fact that the incredible hope was there
or they didn't care they just suddenly
saw a ship but you would think there was
a ship of unknown origins heading
towards the planet Earth but somebody
would stop to ask you a question and say
hey does anybody know what's going on
with that ship right there because it's
big and it's heading here and we don't
know what's on it so you know the fact
that that didn't happen begged a few
questions but at the very least it was
just for the sake of storytelling but
the fact remains here that we
essentially picked up on the moon the
blue area of the moon now this is a big
deal because what this does is this ties
into the existing chronology of the
inhumans back before really back before
all-new all-different marvel but with
the Inhumans during Paul Jenkins run of
the inhuman event which was like you
know Inhumans volume 2 or volume 3 I
think this was essentially a set of
events whereby Black Bolt had
orchestrated a massive duping he had
basically just duped and the Inhumans
and tricked them into leaving Earth and
going to the blue area of the moon and
that's where the Inhumans have been the
entire time now for those of you guys
who don't know the blue area of the moon
is this oxygen-rich part of the Moon
it's literally a section on the moon
where you can walk around without any
measure of protection and you can
breathe just fine it's actually a huge
talking point in Marvel like a lot of
people have been there apocalypse has
been there when he kidnapped a nathan
summers who went on to become cable or
the exponent visited there a multitude
of times it's a huge staging ground like
a huge battleground in the history of
Marvel's publications they always return
there and some form or fashion
but the Incredible Hulk coming here is
due to the fact that Black Bolt was part
of the Illuminati because remember he's
waging a war against the Illuminati here
now with regards to Black Bolt his voice
his quasi sonic scream has varied over
time in terms of how strong it is Marvel
Comics there's been times where it's
been shown capable of destroying planets
there's been times when it's only shown
capable of destroying like a small
satellite like a small planet or a small
moon or something like that in this
instance his voice is if I recall
correctly is kind of in the middle of
the ground where it's not strong enough
to destroy a planet but it is stronger
that's strong enough to destroy a moon
now when I say his voice is in the
middle ground I mean if you were to just
kind of whisper or talk at a normal rate
a regardless of what writers do a
regardless of where he's been at in his
publication history if Black Bolt were
to scream as loud as possible he would
wipe out a planet I mean it's always
been that way like if he screams as loud
as he can that planet will be destroyed
with the Incredible Hulk being here as
soon as he shows up you know when he
tells Black Bolt like dude I'm gonna
take you out like I'm going to destroy
you
Black Bolt simply just kind of whispers
enough and it's a it does enough to
basically damage you know the Incredible
Hulk or at the very least it seems like
it does enough to damage the Incredible
Hulk but didn't we learn and one of the
most awesome scenarios possible The
Incredible Hulk says I didn't come here
to hear you whisper I came here to hear
you scream and I was like this is so
badass because it's just the way it's
done it's just it's insane how cool this
looks so from here it's essentially a
scenario where the government begins to
become aware of the fact that something
bad is happening not only that they have
literally chunks of the moon just
breaking away from orbit and so their
question is what in the hell is going on
on the moon but there's a conflict so
massive that it's sending chunks of the
moon into space itself now one other
thing to keep in mind here and this is
something that we'll touch on a little
bit more as we get into this but Tony
Stark is currently the director of
shield this is after Civil War this this
picks up relatively soon after the
conclusion of civil war so we still have
the initiative the fifty state
initiative where we have a superhero
team in all 50 states not only that of
course we still have the Illuminati as
we knew them before and so it's
essentially this scenario where the
world is coming to the realization that
the Incredible Hulk is is a
to unleash hell and this happens when
the Incredible Hulk broadcasts himself
to the world and what he does is he
essentially tells the story of what the
Illuminati are now keep in mind again
the Illuminati always operated behind
the scenes no one ever knew who they
were no one even knew they existed the
only people that were aware of the
Illuminati were the Illuminati
themselves now this all changed really
they came to light during both this
world war hulk event and even more so
during the events of jonathan Hickman's
avengers and new avengers when they were
basically public enemy number one in the
eyes of Steve Rogers as the director of
shield but the idea here is that the
Incredible Hulk is essentially saying
you call the Illuminati heroes you call
mr. fantastic you call Ironman Black
Bolt of the Inhumans Doctor Strange you
call them humans they shot me into space
they didn't give me a trial they didn't
give me you know didn't give me a chance
to to make any kind of peace for myself
instead they duped me onto a satellite
and then I got into a ship they sent
that ship you know across the galaxy I
ended up another you know going through
a wormhole ended up on this planet
called Sekar that was literally a war
world and the result was that you know
while I did form a bond with where the
hope refers to as his warbound the fact
remains that he found a life for himself
but then a bomb went off because of the
ship as it was designed by the
Illuminati which resulted in him losing
everything he had and so he gives them
an ultimatum and this is really cool
because what the Incredible Hulk is
gonna do is he's gonna turn New York
City into a gladiatorial arena it's
badass but he does this he says you have
24 hours to hand over Reed Richards
Doctor Strange and Ironman or I'm going
to do this to every single person that I
find and he literally holds up Black
Bolt now the kicker about this this is
was kind of ironic is that not everyone
knows about blackboard again this really
changed during Jonathan Hickman's
infinity event when Black Bolt had
detonated the Terrigen bomb and
basically caused a Terrigen mist to
spread across the world waking up in
humans everywhere but the fact that one
of Earth's super heroes has basically
been ripped to shreds by The Incredible
Hulk been pummeled to the point where
he's been absolutely obliterated is an
indication that the Incredible Hulk is
not screwing around now again keep in
mind here despite the fact that Hulk is
talking with a comb voice despite the
fact that Hogue is talking with a calm
relaxed tone he's pissed
I mean he's insanely angry now he's not
as angry as he's going to be at the end
of the story but at this moment right
now
The Incredible Hulk is a force to be
reckoned with the other half of this
equation is with Tony Stark being the
director of shield he immediately takes
off he says okay fine
we've got us we got to find some way to
deal with this we got to find some way
to cope with the Incredible Hulk because
if we don't he is going to tear
everybody apart not only that the idea
is maybe we can rationalize with them
maybe we can talk him down maybe we can
figure out what it is that's going on
and so what happens is dr. strange
initially appears so Tony Sarkis says
hey look we need to have a contingency
plan in case things go south we need to
have someone that can basically fought
on our behalf or the very least can go
toe-to-toe against the Hulk and so we do
is they go and they visit Robert
Reynolds now Robert Reynolds
historically has his powers have kind of
fluctuated his powers have kind of
changed you know I have videos on him if
you guys want to you're welcome to check
those videos out but the underlying
theme here is that Robert Reynolds is
one of the few characters in the Marvel
Universe that can go toe-to-toe with the
Incredible Hulk they can stand against
him and so the idea of the Illuminati is
to have Robert Reynolds come to their
aid come to their side and fight on
their behalf the issue with this is that
Robert Reynolds is actually not going to
do that now from here we pick up with
some of the minor whose minor
superheroes really not minor but in
terms of like overall strength in terms
of abilities minor characters we of
course have a Spider Man we have a
she-hulk stepping into the fray and
they're really not fighting here so much
as they're helping to orchestrate this
mass evacuation of New York City because
again you know we need the Incredible
Hulk showing back up here terrifies the
hell out of everybody not just because
it's the Incredible Hulk but again
because he has the strength to level the
entirety of New York City and so what we
do is to basically switch over to to
Iron Man Tony Stark
now again he's meeting with Luke Cage
he's meeting with Doc Sampson she hoped
Wonder Man summoned Williams I mean a
lot of these heroes that cannot just
absolutely cannot go go toe to toe with
the Incredible Hulk and he basically
says hey look you know he's going to
come here you know but when he does I'm
not going to let him just walk all over
us I'm gonna fight him you know I'm
gonna do what I can to hold off the
Incredible Hulk
now again Tony Stark has his Hulkbuster
armor and this is this is really really
important because there have been a
couple moments and the the Marvel Comics
storylines we've seen The Incredible
Hulk go against Hulk buster this one and
original sin original sin I think did it
much much better in the same
that the Incredible Hulk was at about
the same level as he is right now during
his world burger Hawk form and the idea
was that he basically mocked Tony Stark
you know Tony Stark won against the
Incredible Hulk in original sin with his
a Hulkbuster armor and whole just kind
of laughed at him and said you know his
toys you know Tony Stark always has his
toys and they're always amusing but they
don't stand a chance against you
Incredible Hulk and that's exactly what
happens here try as he might the hope
Buster armor is able to hold things out
for a while Tony Stark is able to do
reasonably well against the Incredible
Hulk the issue with this is that what it
all comes down to it Tony Stark just
doesn't have it Tony Stark just does not
have the ability to hold on to it now
the reason for this is because I'm gonna
make a really terrible analogy here and
and I hope it works for those of you
guys who were Dragon Ball Z fans you
guys know that in the younger days of
the series Gohan was like this character
where it's like every once in a while
something will happen
he'll just lose his [ __ ] and his power
will just fly off the charts for a
temporary amount of time that's what
happens with the Incredible Hulk here
his world record form or at least that
the super angry you know unstoppable
force Incredible Hulk doesn't really
come until like the very end of the
story but right now he's still like
insanely stronger than he's ever been
before
he's well beyond the limits that he's
been at previously in his publication
history but as he's fighting Tony Stark
he begins to have these flashbacks to
the time that he spent with Kai ere he
begins to have a flashback to the lot
that he felt for her to the fact that he
was gonna be a father and to the you
know imminent destruction of kyer when
the bomb went off and this just sends
him right over the edge it really kind
of like rejuvenates this anger that he
has and he immediately takes it a Tony
Stark and starts ripping his his
Hulkbuster armor apart now this is why I
say the whole the the World War Hulk
storyline is so cool because under
normal circumstances if Tony Stark would
it go against the Incredible Hulk with
his hook Buster armor he'd be able to
hold out the hook long enough that
either Banner would just lose interest
and walk away or he would just not
really tire out but it would allow other
heroes did you come into the fray and
talk you know the Incredible Hulk down
or it would allow the situation to be
resolved without a massive amount of
destruction that's not the case here the
Hulk just keeps getting angrier and
angrier and angrier and Tony Stark just
keeps pissing him off more and more and
more until it gets to the point that the
Incredible Hulk has effectively
destroyed Tony Stark's Hulkbuster armor
and just kind of left Tony Stark there
on his own to figure out
in the hell he's gonna do not only that
it allows the incredible hope to take
Tony Stark prisoner as his first I guess
the second victim in his campaign to
take out the Illuminati as part of the
Earth's superhero roster so continuing
our coverage of world war hulk in this
video we're gonna focus on the
Incredible Hulk fighting all the x-men
and when I say all the x-men I mean all
the x-men every last one now this is
actually a really really really cool set
of events so the reason why is because
it's just the whole fighting every
single X me how does it get cooler than
that the issue with this is that this
story as far as I've been able to tell
is a little ambiguous on where it stands
of course we know that it's around the
time of the Incredible Hulk shows up on
earth but we don't know if it is before
he fights Tony Stark if it's after he
fights Tony Stark at least I haven't
been able to figure that out yet but it
happens around the first issue so that's
that's really good enough besides it's
just the Incredible Hulk beating up
x-men we can just kind of guess when it
takes place but what this does it just
initially picks up with Tony Stark
meeting with Charles Xavier prior to his
conflict with the Incredible Hulk in the
first issue now the kicker to this is
that Charles Xavier was not present
during the events of the Illuminati
kicking Bruce Banner off the face of the
planet Earth and sending him off to the
events that would lead into Planet Hulk
instead this was after the events of
house of M and so you know at this point
in time Charles Xavier was still missing
in action no one really knew where he
was and so because it wasn't part of
these events he never made a conscious
decision now initially Tony Stark acid
in this Tony Stark says hey man look
like here's what's going on like I'm
just gonna brief you because you're part
of the Illuminati you need to know
what's going on but his other question
is if you had to have made a choice if
you had to have chosen whether or not to
banish the Hulk which choice would you
have made now Charles Xavier doesn't
initially answer him and said we just
basically pick up with the present-day
now what this does or at least what what
this opening tie-in does initially at
least by Christos Gage the way that he
doesn't it just focuses largely on
Charles Xavier is kind of reminding us
where the very least Christos Gage
reminding us where things stand in the
mutant community now on the surface this
wouldn't really seem necessary but a
comic book that's the basically centers
on the Incredible Hulk fighting the
x-men would draw attention no matter
where people were in the
of their understanding of comics and so
the great thing about this is that it
almost treats it like a self-contained
story to a degree in the sense that it
refreshes people with where the x-men
are at if they haven't read anything
about the x-men up to this point now
again after the events of house of M we
know that the scarlet witch's actions
were on a multiversal level in the sense
that she had stripped 98% of the mutant
population of their powers across the
multiverse not just the main Marvel
Universe and so because of this after
the events of house of M there were no
mutants being born this is the reason
why the birth of Hope Summers was such a
big deal in the Marvel timeline because
we've never seen any new mutants being
born after house of M instead there was
just a massive reduction and then the
number just seemed to stop there and so
again you know with with the with the
idea of the mutant population being
reduced down to 198 in total plus a few
who have died here and there over the
course of the events between house of M
and this and World War Hulk right now
this is really just a scenario where
they're all being not really held
prisoner but they're all being guarded
by sentinels within the confines of the
Xavier mansion however almost
immediately after we pick up with this
little bit of a story we suddenly have
you know the Incredible Hulk showing up
in front of Xavier mansion now the first
thing he says is I want Charles Xavier
like I want Charles Xavier out here
right now
you know I want him I want to talk to
him now we're actually gonna learn the
Incredible Hulk doesn't intend to kill
Charles Xavier or even to beat him
extremely bad instead like he's showing
up here because he asked questions that
he wants answered but the kicker is that
you know you have the the sub roster
like the minor x-men that honestly most
people don't really care about you know
who were here right now and they're the
ones are just kind of hanging out you
know with Charles Xavier the beast tells
him look man you got to get out of here
like we're we cannot bring you Charles
Xavier that's not gonna happen now this
is actually pretty important because
beast has a long-standing history with
the Incredible Hulk I wouldn't go as far
as to say they're like the best of
friends ever but there is a lot of
respect between the two of them because
Bruce Banner is a scientist beast as a
scientist they share a common ground in
terms of their overall interests and
views and there's been a multitude of
times where they've reached out reached
across the aisle and talked to one
another in order to sort out various
problems that they couldn't do on their
own the problem with this is that the
Incredible Hulk has no interest in past
friendships The Incredible Hulk has no
interest in past allies instead he says
simply sends Ben Hank McCoy flying along
his way and almost knocks them out in
response to this the ex
and essentially jumped in as best they
can now somebody else who's kind of
sitting on the sidelines here is Joshua
Foley now Joshua Foley is an omega-level
mutant he's really really powerful
within the confines of his abilities the
problem is that his abilities are not in
the realm of you know telekinesis or
telepathy you know he's not an Omega
level energy projector or anything like
that he's a kid that can basically
control the biological structure of
other people's bodies but only insofar
as how is confined to healing so he can
heal from anything and he can heal
others from anything he's effectively
immortal the issue with this is that the
plan of beast is to basically send the
healing factor of the Incredible Hulk
into overdrive for the reason why I say
this is an issue is because the
Incredible Hulk is an uncharted levels
of power here even for his character the
x-men have never faced a foe on the
level of Incredible Hulk
when it comes to sheer strength and
durability they faced wildly powerful
beings what we're talking about beings
with the ability to warp reality stuff
like that but the Incredible Hulk is a
tangible threat that cannot be stopped
the closest that we ever really got to
the x-men associating with someone like
this would be like eight day juggernaut
but eighth day juggernaut that's
something that's someone we'll talk
about here in a little bit when the
juggernaut shows up but eighth day
juggernaut was not on the same level as
World Waker Hulk they were close but
eighth day juggernaut would probably
still be defeated by world breaker Hulk
actually creates a pretty cool
discussion a pretty cool debate eight
day juggernaut I'm curious who do you
think would win eighth day juggernaut or
The Incredible Hulk I'll run over what
an eighth day juggernaut is here in a
minute but for right now um it's really
just these x-men doing what they can to
face off against the Hulk but in truth I
mean this is the B roster you know these
guys have no chance now the cool thing
here is we actually get to see Laura
Kenney fight now Lord Kenny of course
x-23 I have a character ever videos on
her those you guys who don't know
x-23 was cloned or designed to be a
clone of Wolverine but they had to
modify her genes to make her a woman
instead of a guy said well because of
the fact that the chromosomes used to
create her were corrupted to a degree
and so they were just kind of stuck with
with making her a female but she's every
ounce as capable as Wolverine is and in
the sense that she has adamantium claws
in the sense that she is a prodigious
fighter as she was trained to be an
assassin she has enhanced healing all
the same features as Wolverine it's just
a different characteristic of her in
terms of who she is and the backstory is
different but the idea here
that while she does have the same kind
of fighting ability as Wolverine she
doesn't have the same experience and
that's what that's what makes a whole
different thing now she is capable
because she's assassinated people she's
been in a lot of different conflicts but
she's never gone toe-to-toe with the
Incredible Hulk Wolverine has Logan has
gone against the Incredible Hulk in a
multitude of occasions and so he knows
how to engage the hoch effectively and
this proves itself in the fact the next
23 has no chance here I mean she has
adamantium she manages to scrape his
face but the incredible hope grabs her
and just throws her into a wall and
that's that you know that she's she has
nothing to offer in this situation and
so again from here it's really just the
Incredible Hulk turning his attention to
everyone he can find until we get to a
roster of the x-men showing up and this
is Wolverine this is Cyclops Emma Frost
Colossus Kitty Pryde Colossus is
actually a really cool situation in this
fight - it's really really funny what
have I mean it's not funny what happens
to him but it's it's it's kind of funny
it's kind of funny like it's cool but
the idea here is that Charles Xavier
says okay fine you know look The
Incredible Hulk II didn't show up here
for no reason alright it's not like he's
just on a rampage you know we know he's
demanding members of the Illuminati
again the x-men don't know about the
Illuminati but if the mind of Charles
Xavier he's like he's demanding my
fellow members of the Illuminati it has
something to do with what they made this
coming you know combined with what it
was that Tony Stark told me indicates
the Incredible Hulk has come back here
to unleash hell on us all he's come back
here to destroy us as the Illuminati and
so what we do here is we transition with
you know Charles Xavier s he goes
through and begin scanning the mind of
of the Incredible Hulk now what's funny
about this as Charles Xavier tells us
that in years past it's never been
exhale E difficult to scan the mind of
the incredible hope it was always
relatively difficult because the hoax
line was really more of a primal force
more so than inaccessible or something
like that but the idea here is that the
Incredible Hulk is filled with so much
rage right now that it's almost created
his own self-sustaining barrier against
the powers of Charles Xavier he is able
to penetrate but when he does he finds
the source of this anger he finds out
the Incredible Hulk had effectively been
tortured been forced into combat as a
gladiator he had found love and then
lost love and all of that happened
because of the actions of the Illume
and so Charles Xavier is kind of an a
situation right here where he's like
there's nothing we can do to stop him
right now like he's not gonna be able to
listen the reason more so than that
what Charles Xavier saw was projected
into the minds of all the other x-men as
Charles Xavier was seeing it and so it's
not like the x-men don't know why the
Hulk is here now they all understand why
he's here but the idea is that they've
essentially come to the realization that
there's no talking sense
to the Incredible Hulk right now The
Incredible Hulk is in a state of
absolute madness he's almost feral in
terms of how angry he is and he's in a
level of uncharted strength and
durability here and so while the other
x-men are temporarily incapacitated he
asked Charles Xavier the most important
question he says you know look I know
that you were not part of the Illuminati
when I was banished from this world I
know that you know from what Blackwell
told me you're not here he doesn't know
everything about house of M but he knows
that Charles Xavier was not here when
that happened but he asked the question
if you had to make a choice if you had
to you know vote who would you a vote it
would you have kicked me out or would
you have kept me here on the planet
Earth now Charles Xavier does provide a
definitive answer here he beats around
the bush for a little bit you know he
kind of toys around for a little bit but
he says look I would not have agreed to
kicking you out of earth for eternity I
would not have forced you to leave what
I would have done is I would have said
we need to remove you from the earth
until we can find a cure the problem
with this for the Incredible Hulk is
that there's no real difference here
whether it was Charles Xavier
you know banishing him or exiling him
until they could find a cure or exiling
him forever it's all the same thing and
the reason why we know this is because
Charles Xavier says look fine if you
want to take me you can take me I will
go with you I will effectively give up I
will surrender and the Hulk says cool
let's go but but you know of course
Colossus and the other x-men step in and
they say no no no you're not taking
Charles Xavier anywhere now we know with
the x-men they have a massive amount of
respect for Charles Xavier but this is
that in-between period this is that
period where the line of x-men
publications are starting to see Cyclops
begin to break away from the teachings
of Charles Xavier and start to leave him
behind now all of that really came to a
head in Avengers vs. x-men but the idea
is that this is kind of the the rift
being formed this is Cyclops beginning
to look away from the idea of Charles
Xavier moving away from his teachings
and ultimately stepping into his own as
the de facto leader of the x-men for the
most part now of course with the other
x-men stepping in and doing
they can I mean they put up one hell of
a fight I mean you have Cyclops using
the full blast of his optic blast you
have a Wolverine who uses this cause as
best he can you know of course to try to
fight off the Incredible Hulk here but
none of them are really able to do
anything to hold their own Emma Frost
even goes as far as to say hey look I'm
joining the fight here you know my my
daughter's you know my clones more or
less the Stepford cuckoos
I'm monitoring the entire fight and so
if you try to step in and stop us from
fighting we'll shut your mind down and
so it's really her saying go in and tend
to the wounded do not get in the way now
again this is of course you know just
the idea that they're breaking away I
mean again you know after the events of
house of am during the decimation
storyline which calls Xavier was
absentee it was really left to Emma
Frost and to Cyclops to run the x-men
team and so in their mind Charles Xavier
is now an Una's central part of the
x-men roster they've really proven they
can run it without him they don't really
need him his return is welcomed but his
return is also somewhat inconvenient for
Emma and Cyclops in the sense that again
they don't feel like they need him and
this is just really Marvel continuing
this trend of the x-men or at least of
Emma Frost Cyclops saying look it's cool
that you're here but you're just kind of
getting in the way at this point because
all you can do is use telepathy and
you've essentially already given up so
you're really more of a hindrance you
know it's essentially one of those
things where you know it's like if
you're not part of the solution you're
part of the problem and so they
basically send Charles Xavier back into
the mansion which is really wild to see
to sitting you know to see some measure
of respect given here but to also see a
vast amount of disrespect to the guy
that literally laid the groundwork for
what the x-men will become in terms of
Marvel Comics but at the very least you
know because of the story as it goes
right now I mean this is really kind of
a necessity too because of the Charles
Xavier having telepathy there's really
not a whole lot he can do I mean Emma
Frost wouldn't even be part of this
conflict if she didn't have a secondary
mutation that allowed her to take on her
diamond form but because she has this I
mean she can step in and she has you
know a reasonable measure of durability
against the Incredible Hulk but at the
end of the day I mean she's not strong
enough to put a little put up a
legitimate fight and take the Incredible
Hulk out now if we're here we actually
pick up with Kitty Pryde and Kitty Pryde
is actually really interesting in this
situation because normally we wouldn't
consider her to be an essential part of
the story we would kind of laugh it off
and say well I was Kitty Pryde whatever
but what she does is she phases the
Incredible Hulk into the ground now as
we know with the Incredible Hulk his
strength you know just increases the
angrier he
yes and so this is really more of a
stopgap measure and in fact even you
know beast says yeah this is really cool
but this is also a stopgap measure we
have to find something that we need to
do I mean we got to find something to do
with him now
they initially tore with the idea of
filling him in the prison and the
negative zone because remember during
the events of civil war Reed Richards
and Hank Pym and Tony Stark built prison
42 they built a prison in the negative
zone to house those superheroes who
refused to register with the superhuman
Registration Act and they initially
considered throwing the Incredible Hulk
in there because if they put him in
there and they closed the portal he'll
never be able to get back out but he
literally just be stuck in the negative
zone but the result is that as they're
in the middle of having this discussion
he suddenly breaks himself free now at
this point is really the x-men sending
out an SOS I mean you have the younger
mutants watching all these events unfold
you have you know the Stepford cuckoos
who are watching everything happen and
the idea here is okay look the x-men
can't do this on their own like we've
seen the x-men cannot deal with the
Incredible Hulk in this level of rage
and so what they do is they send out a
message to everybody to Jamey mad rocks
in the x-factor investigations to siren
the daughter I think it is of banshee
who has like this screen that can
disorient people and allow her to fly
they send it out to anybody who's
listening anyone you know Excalibur
anybody who is listening to this or at
the very least is aware or familiar with
the x-men the message goes out to them
all now Excalibur doesn't initially step
in you know Captain Britain Dazzler they
kind of stay behind but we end up having
the juggernaut who actually takes his
crimson gem of cyttorak and communes
directly with Sid Iraq himself now again
we'll get a little more into what this
means in terms of this sort of D you
know repowering of the juggernaut in
terms of hey Marco you know how we
normally functions versus a full amount
or at least a strong amount of the power
of Sid Iraq but the idea is that while
this is happening the Exeter just kind
of buying time the actually are doing
the best they can now Hulk turns his
sights to Emma Frost and he says you're
in tough situation here and the reason
why is because you can't use your
telepathy while you are in your diamond
form and in order to use your telepathy
you have to leave your diamond form but
if you do I have a hold of you which
means that if you get out of your
diamond form I'm going to destroy you
and so it's just this this funny
scenario now in truth the Incredible
Hulk could probably crush her in her
diamond form right now with him being as
strong as he is but before he's able to
do any one of those things we have
losses stepping in now this is why I say
things get so cool with Colossus because
historically Colossus has never been
like eco with The Incredible Hulk
in terms of power and the incredible
hoax baseline form sure but the
Incredible Hulk just keeps getting
stronger
you know Colossus does not have an
infinite level of strength he turns into
his organic metal form and he's as
strong as he's gonna get you know he
doesn't get any you know any stronger
than where he is in this form right now
he goes against the Incredible Hulk and
The Incredible Hulk even goes as far as
to say hey man there was probably a time
when you were mine equal there was
probably a time when for a little while
you would have been able to hold your
own against me he's like but right now
you don't have a chance my friend and he
actually breaks the arms of Colossus in
his organic metal form now the reason
why this is a big deal is because rarely
have we ever seen anybody physically
harm Colossus in his organic metal form
in truth the only people who have been
able to do that or who could do that are
of course the Incredible Hulk in this
situation magneto who can control metal
Caloris manga knows his daughter who can
control metal and aside from that that's
really it you know I mean you know you
have like uh you have Wolverines
adamantium which could probably cut
through Colossus but we've never really
had a reason aside from you know some
what-if story somewhere where Wolverine
kills him our universe we didn't really
had a reason to ask the question of
whether or not Wolverine cut a puncture
Colossus organic metal skin but the idea
is that Wolverine effectively jumps back
into the fray and begins going against
the Incredible Hulk again now here's the
other half of this equation when it
comes to the Hulk going against
Wolverine in almost all of their
previous conflicts Wolverine was always
the smarter guy you know the Hulk in
their previous engagements was just
raging he was a guy who was you know he
was he was going aggro on on the
Wolverine you know he was literally just
fighting and fighting and punching and
punching but never really thinking about
what was going on
whereas Wolverine was usually able to
outpace him he was able to dance around
him he was able to get past him whatever
is he needed to do with the Incredible
Hulk in this situation right now he's
he's a thinking machine I mean he's a
guy that's got the full faculties of his
normal self he's able to think on you
know I'm normal way than he usually is
and so because of this he asked the
question well if I can't break your you
know adamantium skeleton if I can't
destroy that inside your adamantium
skeleton are the same fluids and the
same marrows as a normal person has but
he says the adamantium skeleton also
houses your brain so here's a question
if I start smashing your head against
the ground as hard as I can and your
brain starts smashing against the side
of your skull what's gonna happen and he
says let's find out and so we just start
smashing his head into the ground and
it's cool it's because it's something
that we've never really seen the
incredible hooks sit down and think
about before and this is one of the
reasons why the world war hawk story
works out so well it's because it's a
really intelligent Incredible Hulk at
the absolute peak of his strength going
against some of the most formidable
heroes in the history of Marvel Comics
and so it just comes out awesome now
from here we pick up with the arrival of
juggernaut and this is not a fully
powered que Marco not even you know not
even by 50% and this is shown in the
fact that as soon as he arrives and he
tries to go against the Hulk the Hulk
just takes him out immediately I mean
just like get out of here down for the
count and so we basically pick up with
whoever's left I mean we had different
people like strong guy we have Wolfsbane
we have Nightcrawler
warpath you know we have Jimmy mad rocks
we even have Darwin and this is actually
a really cool situation because Darwin
isn't omega-level mutant but his mutant
power is basically to allow his body to
do whatever it needs to do for him to
survive a situation so he's like the
extreme example of a survivalist now
when they arrive here again it's much
like before they start going through and
they all start trying to take the
Incredible Hulk out now the cool thing
is that none of them are really able to
do it I mean strong guy in warpath are
the only ones that have the power to
really pull this off Darwin with his
ability to you know again alter his body
structure his body automatically
altering its structure in order to
ensure a survival basically redesigns or
restructures itself in a way to where
you're gonna start absorbing gamma
radiation now the idea here is that
because the Incredible Hulk himself is
powered by gamma radiation is
essentially a scenario where he's
operating much like a battery under
normal circumstances the Incredible Hulk
can be exhausted the incredible hulks
you know gamma radiation can be siphoned
off to a point where he becomes
incredibly exhausted and just reverts
back to his banner form it's happened in
a multitude of times in Marvel Comics
the issue with this is that because of
the fact that the Incredible Hulk is so
angry he's virtually limitless right now
there is no end to his reservoir of
gamma radiation and so as Darwin siphons
it off more just keeps coming and coming
and coming
and so ultimately there's nothing he can
do here in fact his body actually comes
to the realization that he can't stop
the Incredible Hulk and so instead of
taking on some
a mutation like you know infinite
strength or something like that instead
Darwin's body just teleports him outta
there and that's it
and it's a really funny running funny
scenario because he oh nightcrawler
comments on this he's like well I mean
if Darwin's body allows him to survive
any situation and Darwin left his body
teleported him away well then it's
obvious the only way to survive the
situation is to not be here now at this
point we switch over to strong guy now
strong guy has a long running history in
the realm of Marvel Comics he's not new
now by any stretch of the imagination
he's been in I guess part of the
x-factor with the second iteration after
Louise Simonson and Walter Simonson left
so he's like the nineties x-factor when
they were essentially a
government-sanctioned superhero team but
strong guys powers or almost uh I guess
almost identical to the powers of
sebastian shaw in the sense that
sebastian shaw can absorb kinetic energy
and then channel that energy back out in
terms of physical strength
that's what strong guy does and strong
guy literally you know takes the power
takes the punches of the Incredible Hulk
and turns them on and turns into
physical energy and punches him back the
problem with this and this is actually
kind of the weakness the strong guys
have for quite some time is that he
cannot absorb an infinite amount of
power right I mean he's not like Bishop
you know he's not like Bishop we could
absorb infinite power as long as he
doesn't allow his body to overrun and as
long as he just you know allows that
energy out as it needs to be let out a
strong guy if he's hit with enough power
will die his heart will literally shut
down or his body will explode and so
because of this you know it's it's this
situation where they're basically saying
hey look man you know strong guy we like
you trying to take on the Incredible
Hulk but you know if you absorb too much
of an impact from The Incredible Hulk it
will destroy your heart your heart will
literally just shut down and you will
die and so again this is really just
strong guy being forced out of this
situation more so than being
successfully to feed it and so at this
point we have Nightcrawler jumping in
now this is the cool thing because I
love Nightcrawler me as a character in
terms of character development in terms
of how he's grown over the years
Nightcrawler is awesome you know Kurt
Wagner is one of my favorite characters
in all of Marvel Comics and our initial
idea would be well surely we can have
Nightcrawler just teleport the
Incredible Hulk away I mean could you
just like teleport him to another
dimension or something like that but the
issue is that the incredible hooks mass
is far too large now that's the way it
works with Nightcrawler Nightcrawler
can't teleport something like like it's
not like Galactus could show up on earth
and the Nightcrawler could teleport him
away my collar can only teleport things
of a certain size or of a certain mass
and
Incredible Hulk is similar just too big
for him now in truth the reason why
Nightcrawler has this has this limit to
his powers is just for the sake of
storytelling
if Nightcrawler had an unlimited amount
or if he could teleport people of an
unlimited size and ability one truth he
would be like Exodus but if you were
able to do that then anytime anybody
should have to fight the x-men fans
would ask the question well why does the
night ball just teleport I'm away so I
don't have to worry about it so we just
allows Marvel to create some compelling
stories with this character which
actually works out I mean in truth this
isn't really something that I would look
at and say well that's just ridiculous I
mean it makes sense you know as far as I
go when it when it comes to reading the
x-men but we also have a scenario where
another member of nightcrawlers team had
effectively taken off - we had
effectively taken off to grab the the
black wing of x-men jet the x-jet and
what she does is she actually crashes it
into the Incredible Hulk now this was a
two-stage plan between Nightcrawler and
his teammate I can't member her name for
the life of me but it's a - a two-part
plan between the two of them and the
idea is for Nightcrawler to basically
move the Incredible Hulk just slightly
just enough that it puts him in the
direct path because again he can't
teleport him that far away the other
half is to crash the x-men's jet
directly into him for the purpose of you
know allowing the Blackbird to explode
and hopefully you know the very least
incapacitating the Incredible Hulk this
doesn't happen like this this is not
what happens in fact the Incredible Hulk
basically just emerges from the wreckage
now this is when we start getting into
the territory of the juggernaut at his
absolute strongest well I guess
juggernaut at his absolute strong it's
just kind of a kind of a misnomer but
when he first showed up here he was not
fully powered and the reason why is
because the amount of energy that
juggernaut can use from city rockers
siphon from city rock to give him his
own durability and strength it's
relative to his motives and so what we
learned here is that the juggernaut
showing up here was to save I guess to
protect his his stepbrother to protect
Charles Xavier but that was a weak
reason at best because it doesn't fit
into the nature of Cain Marko it doesn't
allow him to give his full self over to
the power of the crimson gem of cyttorak
and so because of this what he does he
basically reveals his true motive he
allows himself to fully be handed over
and he says well my goal here is to just
trash the incredible whole to prove to
everybody that the juggernaut is still
the strongest being out there and so we
basically imbues the full power or at
least
almost entirely the full power of citta
right now the reason why I say it's
almost the entire power is because
during the history of Marvel Comics
there was a storyline called the eighth
day which talked about the octet since
and I've got videos on that and so on
and so forth but juggernaut was chosen
to be the avatar of cyttorak a being
from the Crimson dimension that provides
Doctor Strange with his crimson bands to
keep people in prison but also supply
juggernaut or I guess was a reason why
juggernaut found the Crimson gem of
cyttorak during the eighth day storyline
juggernaut was imbued with the full
strength the full power of CID Iraq
which basically made juggernaut as
strong as he was ever going to be and so
he's referenced as eighth day juggernaut
that's where that comes from that
version of juggernaut was insanely
strong not on the same level as well
breaker hawk but insanely strong and so
this version of juggernaut basically
goes against Hulk as best he can and The
Incredible Hulk recognizes you know
again because this is gemenon because
he's as strong as he is if the
juggernaut starts moving no one's gonna
be able to stop him not even wall
breaker Hulk and so will burger hooks is
okay fine then what does use your
momentum against you and literally just
sends him on his way now at this point
you know with the juggernaut running
it's really more a matter of momentum
and so as long as it takes him to get up
to speed it takes him as long if not
twice as long to slow down turn back
around and then head back to where he
was before and so at this point Polk's
sits down and and tells Charles Xavier
look man like it'll be a while before
juggernaut gets back here and while
we're waiting on him you're gonna come
with me now this is where the incredible
hope basically learns about what went on
behind the scene this is really him
learning about the events of decimation
misses him learning about how some of
the mutants have been killed since the
events of house of M and so the
Incredible Hulk essentially is this kind
of a lackluster ending to the story
really
but the Incredible Hulk comes to the
realization that Charles Xavier views
the entire House of M event as his fault
now the reason why Charles Xavier says
that or why he views it as his fault is
because when the Scarlet Witch created
the House of M she had kidnapped Charles
Xavier and used his telepathy to read
the minds of everybody in the world
and give them the life that they desired
or at least all the superheroes and
given the lives they desired and so even
if it was against his will Charles
Xavier was complicit in House of M and
so because of this you know when
everything came back to normal and
Charles Xavier returned he looked at the
mutant population and said this is my
fault or the Scarlet Witch had not used
my brain to read the minds of all the
superheroes and Anish
the house of M the deep howling of
mutants never would have happened and so
in the Incredible Hulk essentially sits
down and says yeah man that sucks for
you like you're already living in hell
and so as a result he kind of takes pity
on Charles Xavier and in the end he
effectively just kind of takes off and
leaves Charles Xavier to his own
suffering in his own misery as a guy who
feels responsible for the D powering of
a multitude of mutants across the entire
face of the earth so continuing our
discussion on world war hulk we pick up
with the aftermath of both the
incredible hulk fighting the x-men as
well as absolutely trashing iron man's
Hulkbuster armor so of course at this
point
iron man is like the first prisoner
that's been taken by the Incredible Hulk
now we'll learn that what the Incredible
Hulk is going to do is basically turn
Madison Square Garden into a massive
gladiatorial arena not unlike the arena
from Planet Hulk and he's essentially
gonna try to force the Illuminati to
fight one another but in this aftermath
we actually have the iron fist Danny
Rand uh travelling to Doctor Strange now
this is a scenario whereby it's
basically all the Mystics on earth or at
least most of the Mystics on earth that
still have their powers outlying
themselves with one another but they
also looked at Doctor Strange because of
the fact that he's so powerful keep in
mind Doctor Strange the fight that is
despite the fact that his power was
reduced a bit during the run of New
Avengers it's still this idea that
Doctor Strange could effectively
eradicate the Incredible Hulk easily and
in fact this is a point that's brought
up you know this is a point that's
brought up by by by Doctor Strange
himself when he says yeah I kid I could
destroy the Hulk no problem like it'd be
super easy to do the problem with this
is that we have to find another way if I
were to banish him to another planet he
would come back and he'd be angrier than
he is right now because his anger is
limitless but he says not only that mean
Incredible Hulk is an ally like he has
been a superhero he's just simply pissed
off because we really just brought this
on ourselves you know and so he says I'm
not gonna kill him we have to find a
different way and so from this point we
basically switched to the ground level
of New York City itself and its really
just whoever is left behind and this is
kind of important because within the
realm of Marvel Comics the x-men again
as we had talked about have been
severely reduced a number but not only
that the Incredible Hulk literally tore
through all of them and so I mean
they're out of the equation right now
like the x-men are not going to be part
of the situation
this is Greg pack effectively just kind
of dwindling everything down to the
point where only one hero is capable of
going toe-to-toe with the Incredible
Hulk we of course know if that's the
century but the idea is to also take
what's left of the Avengers Carol
Danvers doc Samson spider-man a Spider
Woman Luke Cage Ares the God of War like
is pitting them against the Incredible
Hulk and his forces in an effort to try
to take them out I mean she hooks here
but this is this is crazy because she
Hulk is one of the only characters in
Marvel Comics that is as familiar with
gamma radiation or at least as
relatively familiar with gamma radiation
is the Incredible Hulk is because she
received a blood transfusion from Bruce
Banner and so the reason why this
matters is that once Banner in and once
she takes on the Incredible Hulk as the
only person that can really go
toe-to-toe with his strengths or at
least it's believed that she can he
takes her out with the greatest of ease
in fact she gives him a blunt force
punched to the face and nothing happens
and so when he takes her out so quickly
you know without ever really breaking a
sweat she simply says god help us now on
the surface this doesn't really seem
relevant but in the greater story it's
monumental because this is effectively
she-hulk saying we're fighting a losing
war like we cannot win like even if we
were to defeat his warbound even if we
were to beat you know were to be cored
and L away and here on the shame even if
we were to take all them out it wouldn't
matter because then we've got a deal
with Big Poppa Hulk and he ain't taking
no prisoners well I guess he has taken
prisoners but what the idea here is that
he could literally just take on the
entirety of her superheroes we saw that
in the what-if story where he killed
them all and so I mean it's it's it's
not like they have a legitimate chance
this is also kind of funny here because
this is also a Greg Pak showing us just
how strong the Incredible Hulk is I mean
you know doc Samson is strong in terms
of his strength I mean he's very
vulnerable she hopes formable as well
and so are Carol Danvers I mean these
are kind of like the powerhouses
Ares the God of War these are just some
of the strongest people now one thing to
keep in mind this is something that I
want you to bear in mind to Thor is not
here remember Thor was supposedly dead
before the events of Ragnarok and so
right now he's still in this afterlife
kind of thing that's why we don't have
Odin's son here right now because I
imagine some of you guys one of the
first questions you're asking is where
the hell is Odin's son where's Thor in
all of this as far as the world's
concerned he's still dead now he
actually comes back after this
during J michael Straczynski zarada I
think or maybe it's the start of Jason
Aaron's run I think it's I think it's
true since he's run but uh but right now
he's he's out of the out of the equation
he's out of the picture which is why we
simply don't see him here but
transitioning over to the fan
for we effectively have storm of the
x-man we have black panther of Wakanda
we have Johnny Storm Sue Storm Reed
Richards they're basically putting their
knowledge to task for the purpose of
developing a device they can at least
sit at least it seems as though it can
reduce the powers of the Incredible Hulk
and it can bring him back down to his
normal levels but the problem with this
is there's actually a debate between
Reed Richards and and black panther and
black panther says hey man you guys
brought this on yourself I'm doing this
because this is a world war now because
the Incredible Hulk will kill everyone
not just you and so if you could turn
its lights in Wakanda and I would be
powerless to stop him so it's really not
black panther helping Neil Reed Richards
because he wants to he's helping Reed
Richards because he has to but if it was
just if the Incredible Hulk just jumped
out and said hey guys you know all I'm
gonna do is just kill the Illuminati and
everybody else would be fine boy Panther
would have stayed in what conduct but he
would have just been like well you know
that's their problem you know I told him
because remember when the Illuminati
first formed Brian Michael Bendis one
shot when the Illuminati first formed
and they asked Black Panther to join
their ranks he turned them down and said
what you're doing here is going to lead
to some major conflict later on I don't
know what that conflict is going to be I
don't know what the impact is going to
be but you are going to reap what you
sow in a reckoning will be coming well
this is the reckoning this is the fruits
of the Illuminati's labor they sent the
Hulk away and he came back unleashing
absolute hell on the whole of humanity
and so once the incredible hope becomes
aware of the fact that the Fantastic
Four still working together once it
becomes aware of the fact that Reed
Richards is sitting over there as a
Baxter building trying to find a way to
take him out of course he travels over
there now obviously you know with with
the Incredible Hulk right now I mean he
takes out Johnny Storm now this is not a
small feat I mean this is not a small
thing and keep in mind when it comes to
like energy based powers Johnny Storm
it's insane how powerful he is he's
effectively the Sun when he beefs up to
the absolute extreme of his powers I
mean when he blasts the Incredible Hulk
I mean he's he's not blasting him with
the full mic simply because if he did he
would destroy the world but he's
blasting him with enough energy to try
to defeat The Incredible Hulk without
destroying the world now this is Greg
Pak basically telling us if Johnny Storm
were going to try to use the full extent
of his abilities and if you were going
to try to destroy the Incredible Hulk he
would annihilate the earth of the
process along with himself and there's
no guarantee he would still succeed
there's an insanely good chance the
Incredible Hulk would
survive he would continue living on
because his rage and his durability is
so extreme right now it's beyond
anything that anybody's ever seen that
anybody can ever really withstand and in
fact we'll actually find out that um
that the incredible hoax power is on par
with cosmic entities right now like this
is his physical strength is on par with
with the cosmic entities of the Marvel
Universe and we'll actually find that
out through Doctor Strange bloch we of
course have Ben Grimm stepping in
there's been a Grimm so I've gotten us
an offer here I mean it's it's it's
almost pathetic Ben Grimm gets two
punches in and then his head gets
smashed and that's it I mean he gets he
gets two swings and then that's the end
of him like he's literally taken down I
keep him on you know the Incredible Hulk
who didn't kill him because the
incredible hoax not there to kill Ben
Grimm the incredible hoax not there to
really kill anybody
he's there to capture people if they
decide it's better to die in the process
of being captured well then you know
worse for them better for the whole but
in his mind all he wants to do is take
them prisoners now at this point we're
met with what seems to be the century
and this is why I say the century was an
important character because he's the
really the only character in the Marvel
Universe that was able to fight be
Incredible Hulk
in his world Wicker form to a standstill
I mean that's that's what we'll actually
see later on but at this moment the
century seems to be calming him down
because rumor the century radiates
energies that quite literally calm Z
incredible hope not only that the
Incredible Hulk always referred to him
as golden man and that goes back to the
era of paul jing is in jail ii when they
first introduced the century to marvel
comics but the centuries energies had
the ability to subdue the hope the
problem with this is that this is not
the century this is actually Reed
Richards and Reed Richards had basically
constructed a device that allowed him to
synthesize the energies of the century
in an attempt to calm banner down the
issue with this is that banner is so mad
he cannot be calmed down and so this
seems like the fight is you know between
Centurion and Hulk himself is basically
Joyce just going to come down to brute
force who can overpower the other but
with Reed Richards being taken out of
where Susan storm steps into the frame
if season storm I guess a Rex force
fields for the purpose of of trying to
contain the Incredible Hulk Road the
very least trying to contain her husband
now what's really interesting about this
is this is also Greg Pak reminding us
where Susan storm stands and this is why
I say people tend to forget just how
capable the Fantastic Four were people
look to the Fantastic Four and they were
like oh you know when they're sore when
you look at the x-men and you
look at you know some of the members of
the Avengers and you look at world break
or ho get someone and so forth I who
were the Fantastic Four really what are
they really capable of well they're
capable of a lot you know Johnny Storm
is equivalent to the Sun and a little
bit beyond in terms of his power Susan
storm can create virtually
indestructible force fields this Sun
cosmic entities can't penetrate that
Galactus has actually had a hard time
penetrating before and so it's not as
though they just kind of explore stuff
you know when they invent things and
they have a good time and they have a
kid they can warp reality the Fantastic
Four are very capable in terms of their
abilities and I love big Gregg chakra
mindedness reminded us us of this you
know I'm glad that he talked about this
there we go I can't talk I'm glad he
reminded us of this because it's
something very very easy to forget when
you look around the rest of the Marvel
Universe now Reed Wretch's himself of
course is mr. fantastic trying to
stretch himself around does what he can
to subdue the Incredible Hulk but in the
end he's just kind of pounded into the
ground now this is really just riding
for the sake of having it but in
response to the fact that Reed Richards
is defeated and essentially taken
prisoner as as part of the incredible
hulks gladiatorial games we have Susan
storm contact this century and this is
really a recurring theme this is what's
gonna happen in the story over and over
and over again it's gonna be people just
pleading to the century and this is this
is what red patch leading to I mean this
is the basis behind this is he saying
everyone is begging this century to step
in because you know I mean I know I've
made I mean I've made videos like hey
look Robert Reynolds is is Marvel's
version of Superman I mean he is
Hyperion is Marvel's Superman gladiators
Marvel Superman blue Marvel his Marvel
Superman but when it comes down to it
anybody with super-strength flights some
measurement to the Sun or some kind of
atomic energy and you know a cape is a
version of Superman because Superman was
the first superhero I mean he created
the standard so you'd be hard-pressed to
find anybody that doesn't make anything
even remotely close to him you know and
people people will say well that's just
that's their version of Superman but
with the century this does not whether
whether he's Marvel Superman or not does
not take away from the fact it's insane
how powerful he has even in what he's
not the void or even when he's just this
century Robert Reynolds and he keeps his
powers in check he doesn't allow his you
know his powers to go you know unlimited
in terms of their abilities it doesn't
take away from the fact that the century
is stupid powerful in terms of his
abilities I mean it's it's it's night
and day and what this story does
actually this is one of the reasons why
having
and what were what were Hulk was so
important is because it showed us the
full limits of his power when he is the
century exactly what his upper limits
are and how far he can go before his
body just kind of dissipates his energy
and breaks down to his normal form but
what we end up doing is we actually pick
up with the Incredible Hulk as he's
taking Reed Richards back to his prison
and he's met with Rick Jones now this is
a quintessential example of the phrase
and a child will save us because Rick
Jones has no powers at least not right
now he's not a bomb he's just a regular
guy but he's one of the incredible hulks
oldest friends and the reason why I say
that is because when Bruce Banner was
first exposed to the gamma bomb it was
because he was running out to the field
to push Rick Jones out of the way Rick
Jones was saved but Bruce Banner was
blasted with the effects of the gamma
bomb and The Incredible Hulk was born
but Rick Jones was always the one guy
who was in Bruce banners corner no
matter what happened you know come what
may if Bruce Banner could trust anyone
it was always Rick Jones Rick Jones was
always there fighting on his behalf if
the Incredible Hulk was was taking
punches left and right you know he
couldn't see out of his right eye and he
was some link to the ground Rick Jones
would stand out put his boxing gloves on
and jump into the fray even if he knew
he would lose he would fight on behalf
of the Hulk and the hope views him as
his real really like his only true
friend and so when Rick Jones steps up
and says hey look man I get to your mat
all right
I get that that these guys deserve to
have their asses kicked for what they
did I get that they had it coming
you know because of civil war because of
the the ineptitude because of the
stupidity of Reed Richards and Tony
Stark and ant-man hey Pam they deserve
what you're giving them but not like
this they deserve justice but not the
way that you're doing this and then Rick
Jones says what you're doing is is
essentially revenge this is not justice
this is revenge now there's a fine line
between the two there's a very fine line
between the two and is all about
emotional state and motivation but what
happens is this moment when the Hulk
seems to be vulnerable is seized on by
dr. strange for the purpose of invading
his mind now when he jumps into his head
and and basically encounters the
Incredible Hulk he does what he can to
go against him but also allows you know
various other superheroes to step into
the fray for the purpose of trying to
take the Incredible Hulk out more so the
Matt but you know Hulk going against
Hercules
you know Hulk only against those guys it
doesn't make a much of a difference you
know The Incredible Hulk
is still able to tear them down
and why dr. strange wasn't able to
really stay in his head is because an
Incredible Hulk effectively had to open
himself up whether he intended to or not
dr. strange could not smash down the
door of the incredible hooks mine he has
to open it up and the fact that the
Incredible Hulk is so angry the fact
that he's filled with so much rage makes
that almost impossible so because of the
fact that essentially all of the
Avengers have failed because of really
because of the earth superheroes are
indeed like all the earth superheroes
are incapable of taking down the
Incredible Hulk
in his world breaker Hall form general
Thunderbolt Ross observing the situation
says these guys have had their chance
we're gonna step in now let's you know
of mice and men is really whether it
says I mean what hope does general
Thunderbolt Ross really have against the
Incredible Hulk right now I mean with
all the with all the weapons of man you
know there's nothing they can do here I
mean if some of the most formidable
superheroes if the x-men couldn't take
out world breaker Hulk if the Avengers
couldn't take out world breaker Hulk if
Greek gods like Hercules and Ares could
not take out world breaker Hulk what
hope do rockets and bullets have but
what this does show is that humanity is
putting up a legitimate fight but it
also shows the idea that not everyone is
okay with what the Incredible Hulk is
doing a lot of people are a lot of
general public are satisfied with the
Incredible Hulk for a couple of
different reasons firstly because they
watch the Civil War event unfold they
saw the hubris of some of these
superheroes and believing they could
control the world but they also saw the
Incredible Hulk was unjustly sent away
by the Illuminati the Illuminati took
the law into their own hands and decided
the world was better without Hulk never
gave him a trial never gave me a chance
to defend himself literally just sent
him to the far side of the galaxy
and so a lot of people are very
sympathetic to where the incredible
Hawks coming from right now but it's
also because of the fact that people
just love seeing [ __ ] get blown up I
don't know about you guys but I love
seeing stuff get destroyed there's a
reason why a video called The Incredible
Hulk kills all those superheroes and
becomes Galactus Herald has a million
views because you guys love watching The
Incredible Hulk just rip stuff up but
Doctor Strange again is doing what he
can to try to try to get into the mind
of the Incredible Hulk but he doesn't
really have an opportunity here but
finally with the incredible hoax
distraction where the incredible hoax
anger and his rage subsiding even if
only for a moment it allows dr. strange
to fully enter his mind now this is
Doctor Strange trying to really calm the
Hulk down from the inside out because
when he gets in there the incredible
hoax mind is a bear
wasteland of destruction and death now
the reason why is because the Hulk at
this moment right now will breaker Hulk
it's not that he's just angry I mean he
is but it's also because he's living in
one moment in time and that was one of
the coolest things about this why I
loved Greg packs run with with whirl
breaker hooks so much is because while
he's being attacked on the outside by
the armies of Thunderbolt lost while
they're trying to take him down while
the superheroes are watching this unfold
inside his mind he's having a discussion
with Doctor Strange now strange is
really bluffing here he says I could
snuff you out you know with a simple
move of my fingers you know Doctor
Strange is full of [ __ ] I mean that he
couldn't do that let's be honest you
know I guess he could but it would you
would require a level of power that he
doesn't currently have right now like it
would require him to tap into energies
that he's not wanting to tap into that's
why I said before I mean he could but it
would require him to delve into forms of
magic they doesn't want to delve into
now in terms of just his basic raw power
you know he could put up a formidable
fight but at the end of the day it
wouldn't really be much of a challenge
and so what happens is he says look man
show me showing your true face show me
what's going on behind the scenes you
know let down your anger for a moment
and tell me where you're coming from and
the Hulk says look you know and this is
actually this is beautifully written in
terms of how it's done the hoax says my
wife's name was Kyra and I hear her
voice all the time that's all the whole
cures he hears her voice when she
whispered her honey words to him you
know he hears her voice what she tells
him that she loves him when she says
this is your home you know it's the Hulk
living in this moment living in this
time when he had a Kingdom on on Sekar
living in this time when he had a future
with his life when he was going to have
a child living in the love that he had
at that moment in his life and then in
seconds it all came crashing down
because of the ship that the illuminati
sent him in now this is really cool man
because this is the calm before the
storm
all right Doctor Strange finally has
banner calm down and he says hey look
we've known each other forever you know
we've known each other for so long we've
known each other for for years and years
and years and he says I know who you are
at heart like you do not want to do this
you know you do not want to be someone
that wants to go through and kill
superheroes you know he says we fought
enemies we fought we fought foes that
people thought it was insurmountable but
we always came out on top and he says
this is no different you know the enemy
here is your hate the enemy here is your
anger your rage and you have to fight
this
you have to calm down and so once
banners finally finally chilled Doctor
Strange essentially takes him on his way
says hey man look I've got you you know
come with me and as friends we will
solve this problem and banner says yep
and I got you to Homeslice and he goes
back into the incredible hook for what
great writing like what good writing in
this story so he's back to a world
breaker Hulk and he smashes the hands of
Doctor Strange now this is important
because Doctor Strange cannot
effectively cast spells if he cannot use
his hands and if he cannot speak if he
loses either one of those things he's
50% power at best
and so the Incredible Hulk is
effectively crippled Doctor Strange
taken away his ability to be the
sorcerer supreme and so at this point
it's just a matter of time before the
Incredible Hulk finds him and The
Incredible Hulk you know takes him as a
prisoner because Doctor Strange is
effectively helpless following that he
goes through and just rips apart the
armies of general Thunderbolt Ross
it's go time is what this is it's this
heat from the word go The Incredible
Hulk just starts smashing into everyone
and this is why I love this so much
because then we switched to Maria Hill
because remember Maria Hill is really
the person running shield right now with
Tony Stark out of commission and so
she's speaking with the President of the
United States and the president contacts
Robert Reynolds he says look I'm the
President of the United States and I'm
asking you for your help I'm the most
powerful man in the free world when it
comes to government authority and I need
your help and Robert Reynolds just kind
of like me maybe I will maybe I won't
you know I'm not really sure that I want
to and this is cool now in terms of
Roberts character I mean on the surface
that's that's that's the case you know
on the surface it's well you know maybe
I will maybe I won't he's kind of
walking back and forth but we also know
that ferrata Reynolds this is a very
dangerous game then the reason why is
because all it takes is for a moment of
weakness all it takes is a moment for
him to accidentally let his guard down
and the voids coming back this this
multiversal destructive entity is coming
back and it will kill everything and if
Robert Reynolds cannot keep it in check
it will wipe out all things in existence
that's what we saw the siege the siege
what if story was the void just emerging
with 100% of its power and killing
everything in existence spreading out
into the universe and just causing
destruction across all of existence that
is what Robert Reynolds is absolutely
afraid of so on one half he wants to
stop the Hulk on the other half he's
terrified of what may happen if this
unbridled force you know you know fully
emerges and comes out here and so what
we end up doing is we transition with
the warbound
of the Incredible Hulk making its way
into the Arcanum of Doctor Strange now
what Doctor Strange does here because of
the fact that his hands are broken
because of the fact that he's not able
to practice magic the way that he needs
to what he does is he effectively
summons the entity of zom this does this
other dimensional entity it's it's huge
because this is effectively greg pak and
dr. strange saying the Incredible Hulk
strength right now is on par with cosmic
entities and the reason why I say that
is because zom was a being that not even
the ancient one can defeat you know zom
is a is a being whose magical power
transcends almost all cosmic entities as
far as I'm aware there was a story and I
came over that story for life me I came
to what it's called what is she was in
well there is a story where zom had
arrived on earth and had overpowered
Dormammu and Dormammu sister Doctor
Strange couldn't stop him ancient one
couldn't stop him in the end
it required the Living Tribunal to step
in and stop zom and send him back to his
own dimension
like that's what it took it took the
second most powerful being under the one
above all a multiversal construct with
infinite power to stop zom now here's
kind of the kicker with us with Doctor
Strange he's not going to have the full
might of zom instead he's going to have
you know a portion of zombies power he's
gonna channel it but it's just because
of the fact that if dr. strange were to
fully possess all the energies of
zombies as far as I'm aware if he were
to fully possess all of them it resulted
his body was being destroyed most likely
he just simply couldn't handle that much
magical energy all right so we are
continuing our discussion on World War
Hulk and hopefully you guys in the
background those those you guys watching
this video they're drilling in the
background in the next place over and so
hopefully it's not too loud it's not you
know too distracting or anything but for
those of you guys who join my channel
who joined comments explained when we
were covering like Red Hulk you notice
we kind of stopped and the reason why is
because I literally came back this week
and we're just doing ketchup so it was
Planet Hulk world where Hulk and what
this video will do is it'll effectively
wrap back around into why it is a Red
Hulk emerged it'll launch into that new
era of the Incredible Hulk under the
writing of Geoff low because again this
is kind of the continuation of Greg
packs run on the care
I guess the conclusion of greg packs run
on the character and so um you'll find
the playlist for the incredible hulk
down in the description for all the
whole content that i have so far and
what i'll do is i'll go ahead and throw
a world war hulk and planet hulk in
chronological order of the hulk series
that way you guys can literally just
kind of follow along with the incredible
hulk going from greg packs initial run
with planet hulk up until you know the
conclusion of this event although it did
kind of predate planet hulk a little bit
but you guys understand what i'm saying
in terms of the most notable stories of
a world war hulk under the writing of
greg pack up into the modern day but in
the last video we had talked about how
Doctor Strange had made a pact with the
extra-dimensional demon named zom who of
course was extremely powerful and it
requires a living tribunal to take him
out
and so Doctor Strange has quite a bit of
power here and this is proven in the
fact that he goes toe-to-toe with the
Incredible Hulk I mean well I wouldn't
say toe-to-toe he's gonna hold his own
for a little while against the
Incredible Hulk the issue with this is
that word we're talking about Doctor
Strange handling a level of power that's
so extreme that he can't keep it going
for the long haul now with regards to
the hook himself was funny about this is
a Doctor Strange almost feels himself
being corrupted by by zoms power and
that's really the way it works no we're
talking about beings in the Marvel
Universe from extra dimensions when a
person takes on the power of one of
those beings that power will corrupt and
that power will alter their perception
it will take away from what it is that
makes them who they are and turn them
into something much much darker and
that's what happens with Doctor Strange
the Power Sword stream that hate to
anger the rage of azam is so extreme
that it actually permeates throughout
his entire being now this all really
comes to a head when Doctor Strange
loses sight of protecting those
civilians that are watching the fight
unfold as he's fighting the Incredible
Hulk and when he throws him into a
building the building comes crashing
down around him and The Incredible Hulk
is actually able to save some of these
people now he's able to break them out
of the rubble and Doctor Strange
immediately becomes remorseful but this
goes towards the incredible Hawks larger
plan of depicting Doctor Strange along
with the rest of the Illuminati as
villains at heart as opposed to actual
superheroes and this goes to his
credence every when it came down to it
Doctor Strange lost sight of the bigger
picture I mean he basically became a bad
guy and in doing so he almost cost the
lives of innocent people in his blind
rage and so the Incredible Hulk turns it
on Doctor Strange immediately and just
overpowers him in the extreme he just
starts tearing him apart piece by piece
now again Rick Jones tries to neutralize
the situation he'll again you know with
Rick Jones as a character he kind of has
a lot
li-huei here he's really one of the few
characters of Marvel Comics they can
really talk to the incredible hope the
way that he wants to because the
Incredible Hulk doesn't see him as an
enemy the incredible excuse him as a
friend now in truth right now The
Incredible Hulk seeds Rick Jones is a
guy who's just kind of getting in the
way but Rick Jones poses such an
insignificant threat to the desires of
the Incredible Hulk that he really
doesn't pay much attention to him and
said he just kind of considers him as an
annoyance I do that just goes in
periodically and kind of gets in the way
and so initially where Incredible Hulk
had the ability to kill Rick Jones he
doesn't and said what he does is he
takes those captured superheroes to the
Klaw tutorial arena that he's created at
Madison Square Garden then basically
says you're all gonna start fighting
each other now this is not arbitrary in
fact the incredible Hulk's making a
point and what he does before each of
these guys you know begins to get into
the fray and before he subjects each of
them to the experiences that he had
he actually allows regular people to
stand up and voice their concerns now
this is a perfect example with Greg Carr
talking about this this is a perfect
example of people who don't know what
they're asking for and what I mean is
that under normal circumstances where I
guess in virtually any situation when
things are bad enough people will
believe what they want to believe and in
this situation things have become
extremely dire in the Marvel Universe
and I don't mean just the Incredible
Hulk waging war I mean everything up to
this point civil war the idea of the
superhuman Registration Act the fifty
state initiative things before that you
know operation galactic storm the
kree-skrull war you know maximum
security all these events had just
continually led to the fact that
humanity was becoming fed up with
superheroes as they exist to now but in
their blindness in their anger and in
the refusal or their inability to know
all the facts they make the best
decisions they can but they make
boneheaded decisions and what they do is
they say well we want the Incredible
Hulk slaw now in truth the law the
Incredible Hulk is posing here is
solving problems through gladiatorial
combat I can almost guarantee you none
of these people would survive the GLaDOS
war you'll think but they look to the
short-term they don't look to the
long-term it'll look to the question of
what what happens five years from now
what happens 10 15 years from now
instead they're looking at what happens
tomorrow now in truth this is Greg Pak
just showing how dire the situation is
these people are so desperate for
something other than what they've had
that they'll take virtually anything if
it's not what they have had and so what
we have are individuals speaking up we
have on the the nephew of Bill Foster
who was killed when Reed Richards and
Tony Stark cloned Thor and that
ragnarok character began tearing through
all the superheroes and killed bill
foster is basically victims of people
who have lost loved ones because of the
actions of the Earth's superheroes but
again it's just one of these instances
where they look at all the earth
superheroes and they see a problem
instead of saying are there some super
heroes out there who were genuinely
doing good things and so again from here
we basically switched to the Incredible
Hulk putting each of these guys through
the ringer in the sense that he says
when he first arrived he had to fight
these various monsters and these
organisms and so on that were on the
planet and he makes them go against you
know one of these giant monsters of
course that monster is essentially
defeated but then he says the next thing
I had to do is I had to fight my own
kind or I had to fight people like me in
the gladiatorial games using obedience
disks and of course these guys have
already been planted with the obedience
dish you know Reed Richards blackballed
Tony Stark dr. strange they've already
had obedience test thrown on them and so
they essentially have to do what they're
told or else it'll fry their brain in
the process and so he says you guys now
have to go against each other and fight
each one of each other and they don't
they don't want to I mean they they have
to but they don't really want to they're
doing it because they're forced to
you're done because they actually wants
you now this again is where Greg Pak
basically says that people will always
become their own worst enemies and the
reason why is because while this events
unfolding while this conflict is taking
place the people who are watching it
begin to switch away from yeah these
heroes they need to understand that it's
not okay to do whatever they want to to
basically just start demanding blood
they're like kill kill kill kill kill
and this shows that people will become
swept up in this situation and it shows
the fact that people don't usually think
rationally in times of desperation they
think irrationally and so what we have
is Tony Stark effectively using whatever
tools are available to him in order to
hack into the technology of the of the
death's-head gar because again they're
basically just machines and so as he
hatched him to the death's-head guard he
is able to turn them momentarily against
some of the forces of the Incredible
Hulk the issue with this is that with
Elway using the staff to control the
obedience tiss she says well fine if you
want to use the machines then we can use
the machines and she forces Tony Stark
to use the machines to basically attack
all of them and so again it's really
showing the Illuminati that they don't
have a way out here I mean there's not a
way for them to just kind of end and
walk away from this whole thing instead
there's consequences they're going to
have to fight to the death and so
finally you know after all this is said
and done with all this being broadcast
on TV or with Tony Stark on the verge of
being killed and the decision being made
by the Incredible Hulk
based on whether he gives us
up or a thumbs-down Robert Reynolds has
had enough
well riddles is tired of watching all
this unfold he's tired of seeing the
Incredible Hulk become so violent he's
tired of seeing some of the Earth's
greatest heroes forced to fight against
one another he's tired of standing by
and watching all this unfold not only
that he also knows he's the only person
that can go against the Incredible Hulk
and that's what he does he says okay you
know what let's listen this let's let's
bring this conflict to an end let's
finally have this stop and so he takes
off for Madison Square Garden now again
it takes him a few minutes to get there
but I would really say seconds for him
to get there but in the time that it
takes to get there we again have you
know Reed Richards who's more or less
being forced to kill Tony Stark but
while this is happening Tony Stark is
successfully able to hack into the
obedience disks and effectively forced
his obedience disk to to be dissolved
and allow him to move freely where the
very least to get away from the conflict
and so in response to this Reed Richards
keeps trying to reiterate to the
Incredible Hulk
we're not the reason why your people
will kill now we'll actually find out
that he's right that the shuttle was not
a bomb it was not designed to explode
after some predetermine amount of time
instead someone screwed with it somebody
set it up to blow up but before they
could really get any further you know
Reed Richards says if you're not willing
to listen that I'm gonna give you one
final chance to surrender and the
incredible hook says or what and the
century finally shows up now this is so
cool because the century at this point
is just unbridled power this is like the
the peak of his character whenever
people talk about how powerful this
century is whatever they say here is how
powerful the century is whinnies that is
absolute max this is the moment they're
referring to in terms of its
capabilities I mean the Incredible Hulk
is on a whole nother level of strength
but the Sentry is right up there with I
mean these guys are even these guys are
dead even well the cool thing about this
is the century almost never lets loose
this is not new to the Incredible Hulk
you know freaking out lashing out
destroying stuff it's a level of
strength is higher than it's ever been
but his mentality is much the same as
it's always been before he just wants to
be left alone right now it's revenge you
know he's taking it out on taking out
the Illuminati but for the most part you
know his experience that lashing out and
tearing stuff up and fighting and
destroying things is not new before the
century he always held back he always
never let his power get to the extreme
because one I mean he's an agoraphobic
he's terrified of his own power but too
because of the fact that if he did let
loose there was always a chance that the
void would come out but in this instant
in this moment he doesn't care
he's actually relishing he's celebrating
in the idea of just letting this
unbridled strength ripped through The
Incredible Hulk and absolutely just
pummel him left and right now again you
know that the Hulk is able to withstand
all this just because of the fact that
his durability is so extreme but for for
the century himself I mean he's just
he's he's excited about being able to
cut loose and he even says that you know
he says does it always feel this good
when you when you let loose does always
feel this nice when you just finally let
it all go and let your rage completely
take over because again the century has
never really had this chance before
something else I also want you to notice
here the way Greg Pak is depicting this
situation the centuries in total control
he is he's not losing intro
there's no concern of the of the void
coming out this century is an absolute
total control of himself not only that
when the Incredible Hulk goes to punch
him this is again Greg Pak reminding us
these guys are even like these guys are
on an even playing field now this battle
could not just go on infinitely I mean
if it were to continue on really any
further than it is right now the massive
amount of energy that's being expended
between their blows the massive amount
of energy that centuries letting off
would annihilate the entirety of New
York City I mean this is really like
atomic bombs trading blows with one
another I mean the sheer force of impact
from The Incredible Hulk hitting century
or century hitting the incredible is
more than enough to shatter a building
let alone lay waste to the entire city
at in and of itself and so in response
to this you know in the background Reed
Richards Tony Stark these guys are
grabbing these satellites grabbing all
the weapons they can deck it that really
pose any measure of substantial damage
capability and they say we've got to
hone these in on these two guys we've
got a bum barred them with enough energy
that their bodies effectively shut down
their bodies just can't handle it
anymore and they revert back to their
normal human forms now the intention is
to launch this weapon but before they do
but we ended up finding out that you
know that Robert Reynolds and Bruce
Banner actually just fight each other
down to the point that they're
physically exhausted you know now some
of this is because of the fact that
Robert Reynolds is just letting off so
much energy that is continually calming
the Hulk down to the point that he
reverts but at the same time it's also
just a massive expenditure of energy I
mean this is how hard these guys were
fighting they were fighting to the point
that in truth they were just exhausted
physically mentally they had nothing
left to give and this is so cool because
this is basically you know Greg Pak
saying
what it all comes down to it these are
the only guys when it comes to physical
strength you know when it comes to just
sheer raw strength these are the two
most powerful beings on the face of the
planet on earth in Marvel Comics world
breaker Hulk and the century they're the
only two they could ever stand are there
yeah the I guess centuries the only one
they can ever stand up to a world
breaker Hulk when everybody else failed
Colossus failed juggernaut failed
century was the only one that could pull
it off and so the idea is that with
Bruce Banner returning back to his
normal form everybody except for you
know here on the shame the war down are
pretty shocked to see that Bruce banners
just a guy you know the Incredible Hulk
is just a regular person now here on the
shame uses this as an example to say
well you know within each of us is an
unbridled force of power you know a
force of nature something like that but
meek does not want to see this in me
does not want to see the world you know
the world go peacefully he wants to see
all these heroes destroyed and this is
when we learned the truth he goes to try
to kill Bruce Banner in order to you
know force the Hulk back out again but
when Bruce Banner dodges out of the way
I guess when he's pushed out of the way
by by Rick Jones Rick Jones is impaled
instead and let me tell you something
Rob Ford let me tell you something right
now and this this is this is for really
reals all right Bruce Banner is okay
with you with you hitting him he's okay
with you with you pummeling him because
the Incredible Hulk will come out and
it'll protect Bruce Banner you know what
he's not okay with you know what he's
not happy with harming the people he
cares about
woe betide the poor soul that harms
someone that Bruce Banner cares about
and that's exactly what happens me
impales Rick Jones and Bruce Banner
drops the hammer on him he goes right
back into the Incredible Hulk again and
just starts ripping into meek because of
his mind
Meek's an enemy now meek harmed one of
his friends only that meek says hey I
was your first friend and Hulk says no
Rick Jones was my first friend Rick
Jones was the first friend I ever had
and that's why I love Greg patch riding
because he says hey guys look this all
comes full circle you know yes Bruce
Banner is a force of nature when he's
the Incredible Hulk
yeah it's an unstoppable force just
cutting a swath I know you guys love it
when I say that he's cutting a swath
throughout the superhero community the
x-men couldn't stop him The Avengers
couldn't stop him the Fantastic Four
couldn't stop dr. strange I a man no one
could stop him he was unbridled
Unleashed unrelenting
power just beating against the superhero
industry as it existed in the Marvel
Comics universe but when it came down to
it all it took was one of his warbound
impaling his friend for the Incredible
Hulk to turn code and begin ripping all
of them apart that's what he does he
just basically starts tearing it all of
them now with meek in the final moments
of his life I mean you know with these
these last few moments here and there he
says I'm the one that did this to you
you know he says after you defeated the
Red King you formed a kingdom you had a
wife you had a child coming you know we
lived in the Crown City it was peaceful
times but that's not who you are
you're a force of nature you are a
destructive force just cutting through
and tearing through everything that you
come across and that's what you were
made for that's who you are you cannot
deny your nature and he says you forgot
who you were when you married Kyra
when you had a child you know when you
fathered a child when you formed a
kingdom when you ushered in an era of
peace and United the clans on Sekar you
forgot who you were and I set off that
bomb and I destroyed the city because I
wanted you to remember who you were The
Incredible Hulk
[Music]
wrong answer
The Incredible Hulk um he doesn't like
initially he doesn't even do anything
he's literally just in the background
watching these events unfolding this man
let me tell you something people let me
tell you something Rob core fan boy this
is when the Incredible Hulk is at his
absolute peak it's it's momentary or
it's it's it's a moment in time I mean
this is the equivalent of Thor you know
absorbing the runes and becoming the
multiversal rune King Thor I mean this
is this is the Hulk beyond any level of
strength he's ever been even in this
moment Anton all right you know meek is
killed by one of the warbound by the
brood you know that brood species who
you know is outraged of the fact that
meek would just sacrifice millions of
people and their own Kingdom for the
purpose of you know jump-starting the
Hawks rage The Hulk himself when they
turn around and they say hey man like
are you okay he's like no I'm not and he
just freaks I mean he smashes his hand
you know he doesn't collapse shatters
almost shatters the entirety of the New
York skyline and his I mean this is just
I've never seen The Incredible Hulk so
mad before but but the kicker about this
is the incredible hoax not mad at
anybody else but himself because in his
mind he brought all this on and not only
that in his rage he stomps on the ground
now we're told that he shakes the
eastern seaboard I would disagree I
think he shakes the world
like I think with some with rage like
this like he just he almost breaks the
world and he says that he says you know
fire your weapons do whatever you need
to do you know calm me down before I
destroy the world because the Hawks rage
is just increasing I mean by the second
he's getting madder and madder and
madder and madder this is a true
depiction of the infinite rage of the
Incredible Hulk I mean there's no
calming him down you know he just keeps
getting madder and madder and angrier
and angrier and stronger and stronger
and it'll get to the point where he will
destroy the world by stomping on the
ground if he continues to get as angry
as he's getting and so because of this
you know Tony Stark says okay fine you
know on this smart fire your weapons so
they end up firing off you know the the
weapons at all these different
satellites and in response
Bruce Banner is just bombarded with this
massive amount of energy discharge and
it forces the Incredible Hulk back into
his normal form but you know as Bruce
Banner this this really just kind of
kind of rounds out the story because as
banner you know he's effectively subdued
I mean he's not dead but he's
effectively subdued and what they do is
they essentially tranquilize him to a
degree of course they take his warbound
into custody
and they end up taking him out to the
middle of the Mojave Desert taking out
to a facility and then putting him three
miles underground so that if he ever
were to lose it again he'd be stuck on
the ground and people would have at
least some measure of notification that
he was gonna lose his mind but this
right here wraps back around alright so
this brings us to the introduction of
Red Hulk and Jeff Loubs Jeff elopes
Incredible Hulk run his his one-year
long run in two volumes but if you guys
are new here to comics explain and you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
hit the subscribe button if you guys
like this video drop a like and leave a
comment down below let me know what you
guys thought about will breaker whole
cuz I got it I guess we're all cuz I
gotta tell you miss one of my favorite
stories one of my favorite stories I
think it gets better though when we get
to like follow folks and we get to world
world Warhawks when like everyone
becomes a Hulk none I mean everyone like
Spider Man becomes a Hulk like the whole
nine yards but it's a really really cool
series of events that come out here in
the next you know a little while I think
we're gonna have a pretty exciting next
few weeks in terms of about releasing
our hope videos but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]